Herzlich willkommen zu Alternativlos, die Sendung Nummer 15.
Dieses Mal geht es um Drogen.
Ja, wir haben uns ja wie immer hervorragend vorbereitet und stellten fest, das Thema ist doch viel größer als wir uns das vorgestellt hatten.
Deswegen werden wir uns aus der großen Vielfalt von Drogen mal die beiden mit dem größten ökonomischen Potenzial heraussuchen, also auch dem historisch interessantesten Potenzial, nämlich Heroin und Kokain.
Beziehungsweise ihre Vorgänger, Opium.
Ja, beziehungsweise bei Heroin dann halt eben entsprechend Opiummorphin. Und da wollen wir mal ein bisschen drüber erzählen, wie es so ist und das Interessante daran war, dass wir zwischendrin immer wieder so das Gefühl hatten, so die Geschichte kennen wir doch, aber da irgendwie steht irgendwie ein 1800 irgendwas vorne als Jahreszahl drin, kein 1900 oder 2000 irgendwas. Und ja, insofern, dass diese ganze Drogengeschichte und insbesondere die Ökonomie, die dahinter steckt, sehr lehrreich, weil sie sich bis auf die heutigen Tage einfach immer sofort sitzt.
Ja, also fast alles, was wir heute für modern halten, hat es schon vorher gegeben. Und es gibt da die bizarrsten Zusammenhänge, die mir zumindest vorher nicht klar waren. Wir werden bestimmt viel übersehen haben, aber wir machen einfach mal, was wir gefunden haben, das ist schon spannend genug.
Genau, ein paar Buchtipps haben wir auch, die werden wir dann so im Laufe der Zeit fallen lassen und die gibt es dann wie immer auf der Webseite.
Genau, mit einer hoffentlich ausführlichen Linkliste.
Ja, ansonsten, ja, wer, wie ihr vielleicht gemerkt habt, wir haben ein wenig mehr Zeit gebraucht dieses Mal, bis wir eine neue Folge gemacht haben. Das hat aber zu tun, dass wir beide noch ein wenig so von den letzten Auswirkungen der Winterkrankheiten erwischt wurden und nicht so klang, dass wir uns dachten, dass wir euch das zumuten wollen. Deswegen bitten wir um Entschuldigung und versuchen mal ein bisschen die Produktionsfolge zu erhöhen, um euch da viel zu entschädigen. Wir haben ja schon schlimme Battle-Mails bekommen, das von Leuten auf Entzug, was dann auch dazu beigetragen hat, dieses Thema uns ein wenig weiter vorne auf die Liste zu schieben. Wir dachten, wenn die Leute schon auf Alternativlos-Entzug sind, wie ist es denn erst mit richtigen Drogen? Also fangen wir mal an.
Ja, die Drogen an sich sind eine relativ alte Sache bei der Menschheit. Und zwar die ältesten Referenzen, die ich da gefunden habe, waren shamanistische Rituale in Sibirien vor vielen tausend Jahren, so größten Ordnung 9.000. Und da ging es um den Fliegenpilz, der, was viele vielleicht gar nicht so wissen, der ist gar nicht so furchtbar giftig, wie es immer heißt, sondern der ist psychoaktiv. Daher warnen man die Kinder davor, der ist auch giftig, aber es ist also nicht so, dass man an einem Fliegenpilz sofort versterben würde.
Naja, also was man dazu sagen muss, das Fliegenpilz hat die Dover Eigenschaft, die eigentlich auch viele natürlich vorkommende Drogen kennzeichnet, dass der Abstand zwischen einer wirksamen, also einer psychoaktiv wirksamen Dosis und einer tödlichen Dosis, ist sehr gering und den genauen Gehalt an Wirkstoff kann man, gerade weil es in der Natur wächst, nicht so richtig vorhersehen. Gerade bei Fliegenpilz zum Beispiel ist das Problem, dass je nachdem, auf welchem Boden die wachsen und ob sie in der Sonne standen oder nicht, kann der Wirkstoffgehalt sehr drastisch schwanken, also mehrere Faktoren. Dementsprechend kann man nicht sagen, so ein Fliegenpilz ist total habenlos. Es gibt auch den einen Fliegenpilz, der dich tatsächlich umbringt. Das kann tatsächlich passieren, wenn er an der richtigen Stelle gestanden hat.
Der historische Umgang damit ist sehr witzig, habe ich nämlich gelesen. Es gibt einen lustigen Reisebericht von einem Forscher aus Deutschland, der eine lange Tour durch Russland gemacht hat, um unter anderem das zu beobachten. Der hat geschildert, dass die Eingeborenen einmal den Schamanen einen Fliegenpilz essen lassen. Dann ist er in seine Hütte gegangen und hat da Visionen gehabt. Wenn er dann zum Fenster gegangen ist, um rauszupinkeln, dann sind die anderen Leute dahin gegangen und haben den Urin getrunken, weil da ist die relevante psychoaktive Substanz ist da drin.
Genügend Metaboliten drin.
Ja, aber die Gefahr ist halt nicht mehr da. Und das gab es auch in Europa, diese Idee mit dem psychoaktiven Urin. Aber aus anderen Gründen nämlich, weil die eigentlichen Drogen zu teuer waren. Und da hat man halt dann die Abwärme sozusagen genutzt.
Ja, also noch mal der Hinweis.
Also Finger weg vom Fliegenpilz, das wollte ich jetzt nicht so sagen, dass man den einfach irgendwie mampfen kann.
Der Anfang wollte halt selber mitzuexperimentieren, ist gerade bei so natürlich wachsenden Drogen doch durchaus Vorsicht angebracht. Man kann sich da halt doch ziemlich schnell irgendwie in die Notaufnahmen befördern. Insbesondere, wenn man halt überdosiert. Und gerade halt bei Drogen, wo der Abstand zwischen der wirksamen und der tatsächlich lebensgefährlichen oder gesundheitsgefährdenden Dosis so gering ist, sollte man eigentlich ein bisschen die Finger davon weglassen oder wenn dann sich jemand sucht, der sich damit wirklich auskennt und nicht so nur tut, als wenn er sich damit auskennt.
Also lieber nicht.
Auch einer der Gründe, warum gerade so diese natürlich vorkommenden Drogen heutzutage nur noch eine relativ geringe Rolle spielen, weil sie heute in der Handhabung relativ lästig sind. Also ist halt so, dass wenn jetzt hier so Pflanzen wachsen würden, die man sich einfach so in die Nase pfeift oder isst oder trinkt, also wo halt irgendwie ein relativ großer Abstand zwischen der wirksamen und der gesundheitsgefährdenden Dosis ist, dann werden die halt sehr viel weiter verbreitet. Also zum Beispiel ein klassischer Vertreter davon sind halt Hanfpflanzen, also Marihuana oder Gras. Bei denen, da ist es halt so, dass bevor man sich halt irgendwie tatsächlich irgendwie ins Krankenhaus kifft, muss man sich schon ganz schön irgendwas reinziehen. Und dann sind in der Regel zumindest, wenn es jetzt nicht gerade um Dauerkonsum geht, halt die Folgen auch sehr vorübergehend und man beschränkt sich eben auf einen Kreislauf-Kollaps, den man dann doch relativ schnell wieder überwunden hat. Hingegen viele andere Pflanzen, die auch psychoktiv wirksam sind, die hier so wachsen. Also angefangen wie von Bösenkraut, Scheligen und diverse Belladonna-Gewächse und so. Da ist halt eben so, dass der Abstand ist sehr gering zwischen wirksamer Dosis und tödlicher oder gesundheitsgefährdlicher Dosis. Und deswegen finden die halt auch nicht so richtig weit Anwendung.
Na ist auch gut so. Ich meine, es ist auch nicht nur bei psychoaktiven Sachen so, auch bei sagen wir dem Fingerhut. Also das ist auch an. Und lustigerweise, wenn man so ein bisschen die Geschichte von Drogen recherchiert, dann viele Sachen wusste man ja früher auch einfach nicht. Also diese Nachtschattengewächse, da ist auch häufig so der Zusammenhang irgendwie mit Hexerei gegeben gewesen. Also es gab auf der einen Seite so die Leute, die schon ein bisschen was wussten. Das waren dann halt Heiler und es gab auf der anderen Seite eben immer, das muss mit dem Teufel im Bunde sein. Gut, aber zurück zum...
Naja, der Punkt ist halt sehr interessant, weil...
Die Allraune zum Beispiel ist so ein bekanntes Beispiel dafür.
Die Standardisierung, also das, was wir heutzutage aus der Medizin kennen, wenn man halt so Naturprodukte, also so Naturheidelmittel hat, denn wenn die ja so genau so standardisiert, das heißt, dass es findet halt eine Extraktion statt, in der Regel, bei denen halt relativ spezifisch die Wirkstoffe aus der Pflanze rausextrahiert werden, um dann eine Substanz zu haben, wo man weiß, okay, wenn man irgendwie, keine Ahnung, irgendwie zwei Milliliter davon nimmt, dann ist das irgendwie eine angemessene Dosis, um einen gesund oder breit zu machen. Und wenn man irgendwie 100 davon nimmt, dann bringt es einen halt um.
Da kommen wir auch nachher beim Heroin noch mal drauf.
Genau. Und genau diese, genau diese, dieser Mechanismus findet sich eben auch bei den, den beiden Drogen, über die wir heute reden wollen, nämlich halt Heroin und Kokain. Also wir fangen einfach mal mit, ja, mit den Epium an.
Also ich hab hier noch ein bisschen, bisschen Historie.
Ach so, ja, wir haben noch ein bisschen Historie.
Also es gab auch relativ frühe Aufzeichnung, ja, es gab auch relativ frühe Aufzeichnung von den Azteken. Also das ist nicht nur unser Kulturkreis, wo psychoaktive Sachen genutzt wurden, sondern auch so die Azteken, die Sumerer, die Ägypter kannten schon Opium. Die Griechen nutzten Opium, also beziehungsweise Schlafmohnen für kultische Handlungen und auch schon Medizin. Und so als Wohlstandsdroge ist das mit den Römern zum ersten Mal assoziiert.
Also sozusagen Anwendung aus Langeweile.
Genau, also so, ich hab Geld, ich kann mir das leisten. Das war zum ersten Mal bei den Römern. Schlafmohnen ist die Quelle von Opium und der medizinische Anwendung davon ist die Schmerzbehandlung. Und eine Sache, die ich sehr spannend fand, wo ich aber leider keine richtig guten Quellen gefunden hab, sondern die haben alle nur in meinem Kreis auf sich verwiesen, war, dass angeblich das frühe Christentum im Rom die Anwendung von Opium als schmerzstillendes Mittel verhindert haben soll. Das heißt, die erste Prohibition wäre dann gar nicht gewesen, weil das irgendwie abhängig macht oder weil man da Dinge sieht, sondern da war die Idee, also laut diesen verschiedenen gegenseitig aufeinander liegenden Quellen, dass Krankheit und Schmerz eine Strafe Gottes sind und man da nichts gegen tun soll. Das heißt, die Idee war, ein schmerzstillendes Mittel wäre, dass der Mensch sich anmaßt, das gegen die Strafe Gottes zu tun, und deswegen ist das verboten. Das gab also ein Verbot im vierten Jahrhundert, heißt es da, und Karl der Große soll das 1810 nochmal erneuert haben. Mondsaft galt deswegen als Satanswerk, weil es hilft, die Strafe Gottes sozusagen zu bekämpfen.
Diese Anwendung halt zu medizinischen Zwecken ist ja eigentlich bei all diesen Pflanzensubstanzen doch historisch schon sehr, sehr lange belegt. Und also gerade bei Schlafmonden halt zur Beruhigung und zur Hustendämpfung. Und was noch?
Opium ist halt insbesondere immer gewesen, den Schmerzen zu behandeln. Überhaupt die Möglichkeit, überhaupt erst eine Operation durchzuführen an einem Patienten geht ja nur, wenn man eine Betäubung hat. Und das ist überhaupt erst durch Opium möglich gewesen. Ja, zu Opium, also eine relativ frühe Prohibition war auch die Sharia, also das ist die islamische Gesetzgebung, die unter anderem eben natürlich Alkohol verbietet, bekannterweise. Aber es hieß eben auch, dass Haschisch und so was verboten sei davon. Und da ist so ein bisschen das Problem, das fand ich interessant, deswegen erwähne ich das hier am Rande, dass die Aufzeichnung dafür unvollständig sind, weil es halt die religiösen Aufzeichnungen haben es alle überlebt, aber so die wissenschaftlichen Aufzeichnungen eben nicht. Und heute meint man wohl, dass diese die Sharia eben nicht für medizinische Anwendung galt. Das heißt, dass die Verbote auch für Alkohol nur für den hedonistischen Einsatz waren und dass es trotzdem noch erlaubt war, das zu beforschen und das zu benutzen, auch aus medizinischen Gründen. Das heißt, diese Ausnahme, die auch heute gerne benutzt wird, und es heißt immer Medical Marijuana in den USA zum Beispiel, das geht sehr lange zurück in der Menschheitsgeschichte. Na, kommen wir ein bisschen zu näheren Drogen, oder du hast noch was?
Ja genau, wir sollten noch die Sache mit dem Bilsenkraut in dem Bier.
Genau. Ja, zu etwas näher liegenden psychoaktiven Substanzen. Also in Mitteleuropa gab es eben das Bilsenkraut. Und das ist benutzt worden über viele Jahre, Jahrzehnte gar, Jahrhunderte, um die Wirkung des Biers zu verstärken. Also Bier, wie wir es heute kennen, das geht ja auf das Reinheitsgebot zurück. Und vorher war das eben so, dass Bier gar nicht genormt war, sondern da hat halt jeder so seine eigene Mixtur gehabt. Und insbesondere gab es...
Mit diversen Kräutern.
Mit diversen Kräutern, genau. Und das hat so eine Art wirtschaftlichen Zusammenhang ergeben, der auch ganz interessant ist, weil nämlich die meisten von diesen Braucheien irgendwelchen Bischöfen und Klostern gehörten. Das heißt der katholischen Kirche. Und das Reinheitsgebot ist zeitlich relativ nah an Luther und seiner Entstehung des Protestantismus dran. Und deswegen gibt es so die spannende Theorie, dass da die Protestanten, also es gibt mehrere Aspekte daran. Der erste Aspekt ist, dass man sagt, die heute in der Reinheitsgebot festgeschriebenen Substanzen sind eben weder psychoaktiv, noch machen sie Woll-lustig. Das war auch eine der Sachen, die dem Bilsenkraut nachgesagt wurde, dass es also ein Aphrodisiakum sei. Und dass das quasi religiös bedingt sei, dass man eben Hopfen nimmt, was eher den gegenteiligen Effekt hat und wovon man heute weiß, dass da eben Estrogen oder irgendwie so was drin ist. Und also das war quasi die eine interessante Theorie aus der Ecke, dass die Protestanten quasi gesagt hätten, wir kommen jetzt weg von diesen den wollustigen Sündensachen und machen da einfach Hopfen rein. Und auf der anderen Seite ist es auch so, dass es wirtschaftlich sehr interessant ist, wenn man das mit Hopfen macht, weil das einfach eine billige Zutat ist. Und wenn alle dasselbe Bier haben, dann ist das auch ein Massenprodukt. Und das ist eine Kommodisierung. Genau. Und das hat unter anderem die Hanse ausgenutzt. Also es gibt da eine zeitliche Koinzidenz, inwieweit tatsächlich ein Kausalzusammenhang besteht, das ist nicht ganz klar. Es gibt da widersprüchliche Meinungen, aber es ist halt ein interessanter Zusammenhang. Ja, übrigens Bilsenkraut. Es gibt da noch Quellen, die behaupten, dass der Name der Stadt Pilsen, nachdem das Pilsener Bier benannt ist, von Bilsenkraut kommt.
Pilsener, ne?
Ja. Also auch, naja, ob man es jetzt glaubt oder nicht.
Aber zumindest ist es eine hübsche Theorie. Ich weiß nicht, wahrscheinlich gibt es dann...
Ja, uns geht es ja hier auch ums Pull-and-Pull.
Gegen Theorie, aber die ignorieren wir jetzt gerade mal, weil die interessieren uns halt nicht.
So, wir haben schon ein bisschen Prohibitionen gemacht. Also relativ spannend ist auch bei der Prohibition, dass das nicht nur um solche Drogen ging, die wir heute eben als Rauschgift kennen, sondern es gab auch Versuche, zum Beispiel Kaffee und Tee zu verbieten. Und ich habe hier mal einen lustigen Versuch ausgesucht. Da hat Murat IV. Kaffee verboten, hat er mich gesagt. Also, Begründung, das sei Haram. Also, erstens kann man sich damit in andere Zustände versetzen. Und zum Zweiten kommt es halt von außerhalb des Islam und sei deswegen zu verbieten. Und das ist sofort, nachdem er gestorben ist, ist das zurückgenommen worden. Und eine andere lustige Geschichte ist, dass auch die katholische Kirche durchaus versucht hat, Kaffee loszuwerden. Aber Papst Clement VIII hat dann 1600 gesagt, das sei so köstlich, das sei ja eine Schande, wenn das nur in den Händen der Ungläubigen sei. Und seitdem ist Kaffee erlaubt.
Man muss aber noch dazu sagen, dass es natürlich immer wieder Versuche gab, Kaffee zu verbieten, eben weil in den Kaffeehäusern sich ja der politische Widerstand formierte und irgendwie das Bürgertum anfing, sich irgendwie zusammenzuraufen und seine politischen Ideen zu entwickeln. Und man eben versuchte über den Verbot dieser Droge oder dieses Stum und Lanzchen mittels, eben da diesen politischen Widerstand auszuräuchen. Also es ist halt auch so eine gewisse Wiederholung. Natürlich war es halt bei Koffein so, also Tee und Kaffee, dass sich das halt nicht so richtig durchsetzen ließ, weil niemand so richtig argumentieren konnte, dass jetzt der Schaden so groß ist.
Gut, das hat die Weltgeschichte an anderer Stelle auch nicht gehindert.
Nee, das hat die gut geklappt. Das sehen wir aber bei Hanf Produkten zum Beispiel. Da erinnert es ja auch niemand daran. Also wir sehen, dass die Kulturgeschichte der Drogen eine sehr vielfältige ist. Also man kann diese natürlich noch aus ganz anderen Substanzen auslehnen, die heutzutage als völlig normal gelten.
Ja, also die Hochzeit des Drogenhandels war der Kolonialismus. Wenn man sich heute anguckt.
Die Hochzeit des legalen Drogenhandels. Ja. Also die Hochzeit des Drogenhandels haben wir heute, was die Volumina angeht.
Naja, also wie gesagt bei Opium.
Gut, bei Opium nicht.
Wir kommen später noch drauf. Also wenn man sich heute anguckt, was die Kolonien so hergestellt haben, ja, das war Tabak, das war Tee, das gab auch sowas wie Seide, das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt Rauschmittel.
Gewürze.
Gewürze, das ist so, naja, wer weiß was da alles war. Also es war vor allem Pfeffer, Pfeffer und Salz.
Na ja, Zimt und Nelken.
Ja, aber also es waren eigentlich jetzt nicht so direkt irgendwie Rauschgift irgendwie, aber naja. Jedenfalls.
Na es waren seltene Luxus-Dinge.
Genau, seltene Luxusgüter, exotische Sachen, die es zu Hause nicht gab. Aber immerhin bei Tabak und Opium, da kann man schon relativ deutlich sagen.
Rauschmittel.
Genau. Bei Tee und Angestellten. Genau. Tee, Stimulantien und Kaffee natürlich. Und Rauschgift bei den Kolonien. Und angefangen mit dem Opiumhandel haben die Portugiesen. Der spannendste geografische, naja, die, sagen wir, die region, die spannendste Region für Opiumhandel ist um China. Und angefangen haben die Portugiesen, die haben ein relativ bescheidenes Volumen, würde man heute sagen, haben die gehandelt. Wir reden hier von so Jahreszahlen 1600, noch was. Und die haben aber immerhin schon jährlich ungefähr 50 Tonnen Opium verschoben. Das ist später von Holländern übernommen worden, der Handel. Und die Idee, Opium zu verteilen, ist später so eine Art Notwendigkeit geworden. Da kommen wir gleich zu, aus wirtschaftlichen Gründen. Angefangen hat es aber eigentlich so gar nicht mal, um die abhängig zu machen oder weil man sonst nichts gehabt hätte, sondern es war halt damals so eine Innensache. Auch in Europa hat Opium sich so ein bisschen verbreitet damals.
Vielleicht sollten wir noch einmal erzählen, wie man Opium eigentlich produziert.
Na, vielleicht sollten wir auch damit erklären, wie man es eigentlich zu sich nimmt. Das ist nämlich auch...
Fangen wir mal an bei der Produktion.
Die Produktion ist relativ aufwendig.
Also Opium ist ja ein Produkt aus dem Schlafmohnen. Also einer tatsächlichen Mohnenart, die tatsächlich artentechnisch verwandt ist mit dem Mohnen, wie man hier so kennt. Und der bildet so Kapseln. Also der hat zu einem bestimmten Reifezustand hängen oben an den Pflanzen so kugelförmige Dinger dran. Die sind so ein bisschen...
Die Größe, das passt ungefähr in den Erwachsenenfaust. Gerade so.
Ja, also es ist halt so...
Eine große Murmel.
Tischtennisballgur sind so die größten, so ja.
Ja, genau.
Und um da jetzt das Opium draus zu extrahieren, werden die angeritzt und zwar zum richtigen Zeitpunkt. Das ist halt eine Erfahrungssache, auch abhängig von der Sorte und dem Wetter. Das heißt also, da gibt es dann je nach Kulturkreis, wo das Opium angebaut wird, verschiedene Instrumente, die meistens dann auch sehr spezialisiert sind, mit denen halt genau in der richtigen Tiefe und in der richtigen Form, die diese Kapseln angeritzt werden. Und da gibt es irgendwie so lustige Studien darüber, wie in den einzelnen Weltgegenden diese Messer beschaffen sind, ob sie jetzt eine Kerbe machen oder vier Kerben und wie tief sie reiritzen. Und jedenfalls angeritzt wird und dann sickert aus der Kapsel, aus der Samenkapsel, sickert der Opiumsaft raus und der verdickt sich dann auf der Außenseite, oxidiert dann so ein bisschen und wird dann, also meistens wird es über Nacht gemacht, also es wird abends angeritzt.
Also wir sollten vielleicht mal die Größenordnung erklären, die das läuft. Wir haben so ein Feld Opium und da laufen dann am Tag eins, läuft so eine Armee von Arbeitern durch und ritzt jede von diesen Kapseln an und geht wieder nach Hause. Und am nächsten Tag kommt nochmal, also dieselbe Armee wahrscheinlich, alles niedriglohnende Leute, das ist unheimlich teuer, das muss man sich vorstellen vom Aufwand her, und greift an allen gestern angeritzten Kapseln dieses, das rausgequollene Zeug ab. Da gibt es auch ein Spezialequipment für. Und ritzt an anderer Stelle dieselben Kapseln nochmal an. Und dann am nächsten Morgen kommen die wieder. Man ritzt so vier bis acht Mal, bis halt nichts mehr kommt. Und sammelt halt dieses Zeug an. Man kann sich vorstellen, das braucht echt viele, echt viele Leute. Ich hab da so eine lustige Zeitung gefunden, hab ich mir den Titel hier aufgeschrieben. Das war so ein Magazin. Es verwies auf ein Buch von 1873. Es schien in Calcutta und hieß irgendwie, wie war das Opium irgendwas?
The Art of Opium Husbandry.
Super. Also von einem britisch gelingenden Typen geschrieben.
Und es ist immer noch das Referenzwerk zum T-Way.
Genau. Es wird immer noch verlinkt. Über den Buchtitel hab ich dann ein Uno-PDF gefunden, was zum Thema Opium immer noch auf dieses Werk verlinkt hat. Also das ist schon alles sehr, sehr witzig.
So und dann, wenn man halt diese Opiumpumpe hat, dann wird die halt getrocknet und zusammengepresst.
Zu dem Einritzen sollten wir noch sagen, das klingt einfacher als es ist. Denn wenn man zu wenig ritzt, kommt nichts raus. Und wenn man zu viel ritzt, dann ist das keine, ist nicht homogen gefüllt, sondern es gibt ganz in der Mitte so eine Unterkapsel mit den ganzen Samen drin. Und die hat so eine Haut. Und außenrum ist diese diese Schmodderpampe, die man raushaben will, und außenrum ist noch mal eine Haut. Das heißt, wenn man zu tief ritzt, dann ritzt man die innere Haut an, und dann geht der Saft nicht raus, sondern innen zwischen die Samen und ist verloren. Also das ist schon, das muss man lernen. Das ist also nicht so einfach, wie es aussieht.
Interessant fand ich dieses Bit, dass in den Anbaugegnen die Kinder zu den bestimmten Zeiten, es wird denen nicht erlaubt, aufs Feld zu gehen, weil dann wohl so viel Dunst von diesem Opium in der Luft ist, dass man davon echt dumm wird. Und in den Gegenden, wo sie so hochpotentes Opium anbauen, gehen sie mittlerweile halt dann auch mit Gesichtsmasken aufs Feld, weil sie sonst halt einfach zu schnell breit werden, einfach nur so von den Dämpfen, die da so in der Luft liegen. Naja, also dieses Opium wird dann halt, wenn es gekratzt ist, wird es dann halt so ungefähr so Kilo packen zusammen.
Na erst wird es getrocknet, ausgebreitet.
Ausgebreitet, getrocknet, in die Sonne gelegt. Und dann wird es zu, ähm, wird es in die Sonne gelegt oder in den Schatten?
Ich dachte ja in die Sonne, aber ich kann mich jetzt auch...
Na gut, jedenfalls wird es getrocknet und dann wird es zu so Kilo packen zusammen gemacht. Und, ähm, früher wurde Opium dann halt einfach geraucht. Also da gab es, ja, also normalerweise wurde es einfach mit Tabak gemischt und geraucht. Das hatte den Namen, wie hieß es? Madag?
Madag, ja.
Madag, genau. Und, ähm, ja, und dann macht es halt irgendwie sehr ordentlich breit und die Welt ist schön.
Wobei so ordentlich war das gar nicht. Also später gab es bedeutende Innovationen auf dem Gebiet, wie man Opium braucht.
Genau, da kommen wir gleich dazu. Na, jedenfalls gut, okay. Und, ähm, das heißt also, die Opium-Produktion ist relativ aufwendig. Dementsprechend sind dann halt auch irgendwie die Preise relativ hoch. So, fürs Opium, selbst wenn man sie irgendwo in Afghanistan an der Farm kauft. Aber eben durch die Volumina, die da entstehen, macht das halt dann irgendwie echt große Teile der örtlichen Ökonomie aus.
Ein Bild muss ich noch erwähnen. Also beim Rumklicken, wie viel Ausbeute man dann jetzt kriegt, hab ich gesehen, dass der Rekord von einem Mann aus Edinburgh gehalten wird. Der hat irgendwie 50 Kilo aus einem Aker oder so was rausgeholt.
Also das war dann wohl wahrscheinlich in Pakistan oder so.
Beeindruckend. Nee, bei sich zu Hause.
Was, in Schottland?
Ja, denn der hat halt irgendwie keinen anderen Lebensinhalt gehabt wahrscheinlich. So ein kleiner Mann aus Edinburgh, genau wie man sich das vorstellt. Ich weiß, da steht das statt, jetzt nix weiter über den, aber...
Du brauchst so richtig Wetter dazu, dass sich da Gewächshausen gebaut haben?
Na, wahrscheinlich. Aber jedenfalls, wenn man wirklich drauf anlegt, dann kann man da mehr oder weniger viel draus extrahieren. So diese Massenbetriebe in Indien vor allem haben da ein bisschen weniger gemacht, aber naja. Gut, wir haben am Ende also so ein Päckchen Opium und das ist dann tatsächlich per Kilo verkauft worden.
Ja, beziehungsweise in den jeweiligen Gewichtseinheiten heutzutage sind, wo Kilo packen.
Damals hieß es Kiste oder so, aber es war auch ein Kilo.
Ah, okay.
Ja. Also warum ist Opium so ein tolles Handelsgut? Also abgesehen von der Abhängigkeit ist, dass man, ist der Hauptgrund eben, dass man wirklich wenig transportieren muss, für viel Geld. Also es ist viel wert, aber man braucht eben nur einen Trip mit dem großen Schiff und nicht 100 Trips wie sagen wir für andere Sachen.
Und das ist halt das, was auch immer noch dazu führt, dass Drogenhandel so extrem lukrativ ist. Also natürlich neben der Prohibition, die dazu führt, dass die Preise hoch sind, aber man muss halt Volumen und gewichtsmäßig relativ wenig schmuggeln, da kann man später noch ein bisschen genauer zu.
So jetzt zur Rezeption, diese Opiumpfeife. Was ist da jetzt das Besondere dran? Du hast das mal recherchiert.
Genau. Also ursprünglich wurde das Opium halt normal geraucht, einfach mit Tabak vermischt und oder mit anderen Kräutern, was wir auch immer da so gerade hatten. Und dann war die die Innovation, die die Holländer, auf die auch noch folger häufiger stoßen, nach China gebracht haben, ist eine spezialisierte Opiumfeife, bei der das Opium mit Hilfe einer speziellen kleinen Lampe, also so einen kleinen, ja, Flammengeber erhitzt wird, auf genau den Punkt, wo die Opiumdämpfe vaporisieren, das heißt verdunsten und inhaliert werden können, aber es noch nicht verbrennt. Das heißt, es wird halt ziemlich effizient und man bekommt mit relativ wenig Rauch relativ viel Opium inhaliert. Das heißt, es macht dann irgendwie ganz schön doll breit. Und diese Innovationen haben sie dann natürlich auch wieder in ihren Markt, nämlich den Chinesen, gebracht.
Es gibt noch einen anderen Hintergrund, warum das gerade super war zu dem Zeitpunkt, weil nämlich der chinesische Kaiser oder mehrere chinesische Kaiser haben in der Geschichte mehrfach versucht, Prohibitionen auszusprechen. Und der Vorgänger von Opium war, wie erwähnt, Madak. Und das war verboten worden. Das war zu ungefähr gleichen Teilen wohl Tabak und Opium. Und wenn beides verboten ist, dann ist es natürlich weniger gefährlich, weil man nur eins davon reinschmuggeln muss. Deswegen sind die Chinesen also auf roh quasi nur Opium gestiegen. Und da braucht man eben diese speziellen Pfeifen für, damit sich das lohnt.
Beziehungsweise ist es halt dann auch einfach wirksamer in der Konsumtion. Naja, der spannende Grund, wieso dieser Opiumhandel mit China so wichtiger war, erinnert so ein bisschen an das, was heute passiert. Nämlich damals war es so, dass China auch so eine exportorientierte Phase hatte. Also halt relativ offen war zur Welt, zumindest was den Export angeht. Und die haben halt primär Tee, Seide und Gewürze exportiert.
Also die Seidenstraße kennt man ja. Das geht ja um die Jahrhunderte zurück.
Genau. Aber da war es dann halt eben mit dem Schiffsfernhandel, die zu den Gewürzinseln fuhren. Die haben dann halt eben auch aus, also die Gewürzinseln ist halt da so Indonesien und Malaysia die Ecke. Und die haben dann eben auch den China-Handel im großen Stil öffnet. Das führte halt so weit, dass die Europäer ein massives Handelsbilanzdefizit mit China hatten. Das heißt also, die haben extrem viel mehr aus China importiert, als sie nach China exportiert haben. Erinnert das irgendwie vielleicht an heute?
Also es gibt noch so ein bisschen Hintergrund, die an der Stelle spannend ist. Die Chinesen waren nämlich eine sehr stolze Nation damals, die sich als die einzigen zivilisierten Menschen auf der Erde gesehen haben. Und alle anderen sind Barbaren. Das heißt, es gab also weder diplomatische Botschaften mit anderen Ländern, auch nicht mit den Briten, die es wohl wirklich versucht haben, um unter anderem ins Gespräch zu kommen über den Opium-Handel und um dieses Handelsdefizit auszuräumen. Und die Chinesen haben auch die Mentalität gehabt, das sind alles Leute, mit denen wollen wir im Grunde nichts zu tun haben, von denen brauchen wir auch nichts. Ja, und so, das ging irgendwann so weit, dass der chinesische Kaiser auch alle Commodities verboten hat in der Einfuhr, außer Silber. Das heißt, Europa wollte nach wie vor den Tee haben und die Seide, aber konnte nur noch mit Silber zahlen. Und das klingt jetzt vielleicht nicht schlimm, aber zu dem Zeitpunkt waren die Währungen in Europa alle noch mit Edelmetallen gedeckt. Das heißt, wenn man einfach das Edelmetall dann rausgibt nach China, dann kann man nicht mehr so viel Währung haben. Und das ist ein echtes Problem geworden für die Europäer, dass denen ihre Wirtschaften zusammenbrachen, weil sie einfach die Basis für ihre Währungen rausgegeben haben. Und da musste also irgendein Alternativ, eine Alternative her.
Um das Handelsbilanzdefizit auszugleichen.
Genau. Und das war dann das Opium, was übrigens relativ schleppend anfing, die ersten, die es versucht haben, war Portugal. Die haben damals eine Liederlassung in China aufgemacht, einen kleinen Außenhandelsposten namens Macau, den es heute noch gibt. Der ist 1999 zurückgegeben worden an China, ähnlich wie Hongkong. Die Geschichte ist auch spannend an der Stelle. Das erklären wir auch gleich, wie es zu Hongkong kam. Also Macau, das war vorher so ein paar Fischerdörfer und da haben dann ein paar Portugiesen gelandet und haben da ein Protektorat aufgemacht. Und das war eigentlich ein Handelsposten auf dem Weg nach Nagasaki für den Handel mit Japan. Macau hat aber auch Glücksspiel erlaubt und hat auch Opium gehandelt und so die ganzen Sachen, die die Chinesen haben wollten, aber die in China verboten waren, die konnte man eben Macau kriegen. Und als irgendwann der Kaiser von China den direkten Handel mit Japan untersagt hat, haben die Chinesen halt über Macau weiter mit Japan gehandelt.
Die Portugiesen?
Nee, die Chinesen.
Achso, die Portugiesen haben es nach Macau geschafft und von da aus dann?
Genau, also die Chinesen haben halt mit Macau gehandelt und dann haben die Japaner halt auch mit Macau gehandelt und dann waren wir wieder gut. Also Macau war so über die Jahrhunderte ein echter Dorn in der Seite von China, aber China hat es offenbar nie für wichtig genug gefunden.
Wahrscheinlich haben sie genug davon profitiert.
Ja, das kann natürlich auch sein, aber ich stelle mir vor, wenn die da Glücksspiel machen, dann wird da eine Menge Kohle abgeflossen sein. Gut, also jedenfalls die Portugiesen haben aus Macau angefangen mit dem Opiumhandel mit China, das waren so ein paar Tonnen pro Jahr, aber das hat sich dann geleppert. Als die Innovation mit der Opiumpfeife ankam über die Holländer ist es mehr geworden und da sind wir dann schon so Größenordnung 87 Tonnen habe ich gelesen, das war 1699, also sehr früh. Die Holländer waren gut dabei, überhaupt insgesamt kann man sagen, dass die holländische Ostindien-Kompanie erfolgreicher war als die britische, obwohl die heute die, ich finde die bekanntere ist ja. Bekanntere, ja und die ist auch die Opiumkriege und so. Also wir kommen ja gleich dazu, dass die Briten alles gemacht haben, das war schon beeindruckend. Heute ist das aus wirtschaftlicher Sicht vor allem spannend, weil das so die ersten Beispiele für eine Aktiengesellschaft waren. Sowohl die Holländer als auch die Briten.
Die Holländer waren die ersten.
Holländer waren die ersten. Die Briten haben dahergezogen, genau wie das heute läuft. Sobald ein Staat anfängt, ein Bailout zu machen oder irgendwelche Vorteile anzubieten, müssen die anderen nachziehen. So war das damals halt auch. Eigentlich war zu der Zeit üblich, dass man so Schuldverschreibungen rausgibt. Und die die Ostindien-Kompanien waren so die ersten, die angefangen haben, Aktien rauszugeben. Und die sind natürlich auch von von Leuten gekauft worden, die Kohle hatten, das heißt Adelige und andere Händler. Und dementsprechend war der Druck, als dann eine dieser Firmen die Pleite drohte, auf die Regierung da einzuschreiten, um die nicht pleite gehen zu lassen. Also wie heute war noch der erste Fall von Too Big To Fail. Und da hätte man eigentlich was lernen können. So historisch gesehen war aber nicht. Also wir sind jetzt die Portugiesen haben Opium importiert und nach China verkauft.
Und dazu sagen, das Opium kam damals in der Regel aus Indien und Bengalen.
Ja, heute Teil von Indien. Die Briten haben da so einen Posten aufgemacht und haben dann angefangen, das insgesamt zu ihrer Kolonie zu machen. Und haben dann ursprünglich sehr gut daran verdient, dass sie da Opium angebaut haben. Und das haben sie dann in Auktionen verscheuert. Und das haben unter anderem eben die Holländer gekauft und haben es dann weiter verkauft an China. Lustigerweise nicht direkt, als sich nämlich abgezeichnet hat, dass die Chinesen da Prohibition machen wollen, waren die Holländer schlau genug und haben das in Java verkauft. Das heißt, die haben in Indien billig eingekauft, haben es nach Java verschifft und haben es dann damit 400 Prozent Profit weiter verkloppt an irgendwelche...
An chinesische Händler....
an irgendwelche asiatischen Händler, vor allem Chinesen, die es dann eben, die dann das Risiko aus sich genommen haben. Also man sieht auch damals schon dieselben Strukturen bilden sich, die wir heute haben. So, ja.
Naja, und irgendwann hatten die Chinesen halt die Schnauze voll.
Mal wieder, es gab mehrere Ansätze.
Es gab halt mehrere Anläufe und also interessant war dabei, dass es dann schon eben um die, ja, also mal gesellschaftlichen und gesundheitlichen Auswirkungen ging. Also dass die Chinesen halt schon merkten, dass ihnen da halt einfach ein großer Teil ihrer Bevölkerung zugedröhnt waren.
Ja, die Zahlen waren beim Peak waren irgendwie 27 Prozent der männlichen Erwachsenenbevölkerung opiumabhängig.
Das war dann halt schon ein bisschen später.
Das ist schon wirklich krass, wenn man sich das mal überlegt. Wir reden ja also von vielen Millionen Abhängigen. Da muss man natürlich handeln. Aber jedenfalls, der Kaiser von China hat mal wieder eine Prohibitionenanlauf genommen, hat gesagt, Opium ist komplett kriminalisiert und hat dann aber den weiteren Schritt gegangen, 1839 war das, einen Sonderbeauftragten in den Hafen von Kanton zu schicken. Und das war der einzige Hafen, mit dem die westlichen Barbaren handeltreiben durften. Also die chinesische Bürokratie hat da schon den Stiefel drauf gehabt und hat die nicht beliebig irgendwie da Sachen hin und her schippern lassen, sondern hat da auch bizarre byzantinische Strukturen an irgendwelchen Beamten und Unter- und Oberbeamten gehabt und die dann natürlich alle irgendwelche Zugeständnisse haben wollten und irgendwelche Gebühren erhoben haben. Also die zeitgenössischen Schilderungen der Handelstreibenden sind also alles andere als zufrieden. Jedenfalls, ja.
Naja, und dieser Sonderbeauftragte hieß Lin Zexu und der ist dann erstmal auch nach Macau gegangen und hat gesagt, da bitte jetzt mal keinen Opium-Handel mehr. Und die Verhandlungen dauerten nicht besonders lange, weil Macau als Stadt war halt extrem darauf angewiesen, dass sie ihre Lebensmittel aus China bekamen. Also das heißt, dass da die ganz normalen, täglichen Verbrauchsgüter halt aus China geliefert wurden. Und er hat halt gesagt, naja, also entweder hört jetzt auch mit dem Opium-Handel und konzentriert euch halt aufs Glücksspiel oder wir lassen euch verhungern. Wir lassen euch einfach verhungern.
Es gibt ein Denkmal in Macau, da steht dran, dass die 45 Minuten verhandelt haben.
Er scheint relativ überzeugend gewesen zu sein. Ja, naja, und dann gab es halt eben aber noch die Briten. Und die, ja, hat er mit den Briten es auch versucht.
Einen ähnlichen Deal versucht. Also die haben da Faktoreien gehabt. Das ist so eine Art Warenhaus.
So Handelshäuser.
Handelshäuser. Und da waren natürlich die Waren drin, aber da waren eben auch irgendwelche Händler drin, die das lokal weiter verteilen sollten und so. Und da ist die halt hingegangen, hat angeklopft, hat gesagt, rück mal das Opium raus. Und die Briten haben gesagt, denken wir gar nicht dran. Und dann hat er halt die Häuser umstellt und die Leute festgehalten, die rein oder raus wollten. Und das haben die dann so ein paar Tage ausgesessen. Und dann war halt ihr Essen alle. Und dann haben sie aufgegeben und haben das Opium rausgerückt. Und das hat er dann zerstört, indem er Salz draufgetan hat und es ins Meer gekippt hat. Und das war, wir sprechen jetzt von über 1000 Tonnen. Also das war richtig viel.
1000 Tonnen?
Jaja. Also das war nicht...
Das ist ja schon so ein halber Jahresverbrauch oder so.
Das ist zwar einmal eine Jahresladung. Also der Vorteil, wenn du so kleine Ladungen hast, du lieferst natürlich dann zu einer Opportunzeit. Also wenn gerade nicht Monsoon ist.
Das sind dann zwei Schiffe voll oder sowas.
Ja, so viel ist das nicht.
Genau.
Und das ist aber ein richtig harber Verlust natürlich für so eine Ostindien-Kompanie. Und dementsprechend sah sich also der britische Stadthalter vor Ort genötigt, seinen Handelspartnern zuzusagen, dass die Krone, also die englische, das englische Königshaus, ihnen Bailout geben würde und dass sie den entstandenen Schaden ersetzen würde. So nun, wir sind wir hier vor der Zeit vor Telegraph und ähnlich. Das heißt, das hat ein paar Monate gedauert, bis diese frohe Botschaft in England ankam, wo die Krone alles andere als begeistert davon war, dass sie jetzt plötzlich eine Jahresladung Opium zahlen soll. Und dann hat sie entschieden, dann ist es lieber ein paar Kriegsschriffe zu schicken. Und wir reden hier also nicht von irgendwelchen kleinen Cans, sondern ich habe hier mal das Flakschiff gefunden. Das war die Wellesley und die hatte 74 Kanonen. Also man kann sich vorstellen, das war relativ dickes Ding. Die Chinesen haben zwar auch Kanonen gehabt, aber die Briten waren eine Technologiegeneration weiter und konnten also schneller und weiter schießen an der Stelle. Ja, die Briten haben sich gedacht, na ja, was macht man am besten, um die Chinesen zu zwingen und haben also die wichtigen Wasserlinien besetzt, also das heißt die Deltas der Flüsse und haben angefangen, die Junken des Steuereintreibers des Kaisers abzuschießen. Und das hat den kaiserlichen Hof in China quasi geplättet, da konnten die gar nicht mehr, weil die haben natürlich auch Ausgaben gehabt für ihren umfangreichen Beamtenapparat und da mussten die also einlenken, das hat nicht lange gedauert. Ja, und die Konzessionen, die die Briten dann erpresst haben über ihren Sieg waren, erstens, dass die das Opium, dass da Reparationen bezahlt werden, für das Opium, was vernichtet wurde, das Opium überhaupt dekriminalisiert wird, also Rücknahme der Prohibition, und dass Hongkong an die Briten abgetreten wird. Denn diese Schiffe aus England mussten ja lokal erst mal vor Ort irgendwo lagern und haben eine Basis gebraucht. Der Krieg hat ja auch ein bisschen gedauert. Und dann haben sie sich eben Hongkong genommen, wo damals noch nichts war. Es gab da auch keine Bodenschätze, überhaupt nichts. Die Chinesen hatten auch kein Interesse.
Es war einfach nur ein Hafen.
Es war halt eine Bucht, aber die lag besonders günstig. Und dann haben sie sich da niedergelassen und haben das für England geclaimed. Und es ist also lustigerweise sehr nahe an Macau dran. So geografisch gesehen.
Das ist halt wahrscheinlich die schifffahrtstechnisch günstige Gegend.
Genau, also es ist die perfekte Gegend, um sich da im Schatten des Windes auszuruhen. Und daher kam das, dass Hongkong den Briten gehört hat.
Und Bestandteil dieser Kapitulation der Chinesen war, dass sie ihr Opium weiter einführen durften?
Nee, dass Opium generell dekriminalisiert wird. Also nicht nur, dass es eingeführt werden darf, sondern auch, dass damit frei gehandelt werden darf. Und das hat lustigerweise einen unvorhergesehenen Aspekt gehabt, nämlich, dass die Chinesen angefangen haben, selber Opium anzubauen. Also die haben einen Schlafmond gebaut und haben unglaubliche Mengen an Opium hergestellt, dann für den Eigenbedarf hauptsächlich. Ja, die Briten haben natürlich weitergeliefert und es gab dann das lokale Detail, also es heißt, dass das Opium aus Bengalen als besser galt und dass sie da Faktor 2 mehr Kohle für gekriegt haben, als für das chinesische Opium.
Vielleicht war es halt einfach irgendwie nur schicker, weil es irgendwie importiert war.
Ja, also das weiß man natürlich rückblickend nicht, aber das wäre sogar meine Vermutung.
Da kann natürlich sein, dass es wirklich besser war, wenn die Chinesen gerade erst angefangen haben, war vielleicht ihre Qualität nicht so hoch. Oder sie hatten ein schlechteres Wetter.
Gut, man weiß es nicht.
Ja, keine Ahnung. Historische Opium-Forensik scheint noch nicht so ein weit verbreitetes Fachgewicht zu sein.
Wahrscheinlich auch, weil die Leute, die Opium untersuchen, immer so ein bisschen breit sind. Da gibt es auch seriöse Fortschritte. Ja, na gut. Es gab noch einen zweiten Opium-Krieg. Da ging es darum, dass die Chinesen ein Piratenschiff geentert haben und die Besatzung gefangen genommen haben. Das lief unter britischer Fahne und kam aus Hongkong. Und die Briten haben natürlich die Besatzung zurück haben wollen und die Chinesen haben nicht ausliefern wollen. Und das war genug Vorwand, um den zweiten Opium-Krieg loszutreten. Und da haben sich dann auch die Franzosen aus dem völlig blauen Nebel angeschlossen, weil sie halt gedacht haben, sie kriegen da vielleicht auch irgendwelche Konzessionen für den Handel mit China rausgepresst. Und keine Ahnung. Ja, und da gab es ganz lustige Konzessionen, weil Opium war ja schon dekriminalisiert. Sie haben dann noch weiter den Handel irgendwie. Da gab es noch irgendwelche Einschränkungen, die haben sie aufgehoben. Und es gab ab dann ausländische Botschaften in Peking, gab es vorher nicht. Und was ich besonders bizarr finde, Christen wurde die Missionierung in China erlaubt. Das war eine der Konzessionen nach dem zweiten Opium-Krieg. Völlig abgefahren.
So als Kompensation für irgendwie die Sünde.
Keine Ahnung. Also ich hab jetzt auch nichts weiter zu gefunden, was da jetzt der ist.
Oder vielleicht war das ja die Propaganda für zu Hause, dass sie, was sie dabei rausgeschlagen haben, ich weiß nicht genau, was damals in den Zeitungen abging. Haben sie denn offen gesagt, dass jetzt der Zweck von dem Krieg war, dass sie Opium handeln dürfen?
Ja, also es gab richtig Protest auch in England von Adligen auch, die gesagt haben, das sei ja wohl der übelste Hintergrund, für den wir je in Krieg gezogen sind. Und wie sollen wir das unseren Nachfolgegenerationen erklären? Und also die haben schon gewusst, was sie da tun.
Okay, aber vielleicht kommt ja genau daher eben der diese...
Das ist so eine Art Buße, war man.
Diese Missionierungserlaubnis, dass sie sich halt noch irgendeinen Kriegsgrund, also irgendein Kriegsergebnis dazu geholt haben, was denn moralisch irgendwie vertretbar war zu Hause.
Also es gab die Geschichte, dass die protestantischen Missionare an der Vorderfront der medizinischen Überprüfung von den Opiumfolgen waren damals. Und dass die so eine Art NGO waren, würde man heute sagen, die geguckt haben. Und von denen kamen also die ersten Ansagen. Guck mal, das macht auch süchtig und das ist schlecht für die Leute. Vielleicht hat es das als Hintergrund.
Verstehe. Merkwürdige Kompensation.
Also kommen wir zu so ein paar weiteren Sachen. Also ich meine, es gibt da hunderte von spannenden Faktuiden. Wir erwähnen jetzt die, die heute noch Relevanz haben. Und eine, die ich zum Beispiel ganz witzig fand, war, dass die Amerikaner auch eingestiegen sind in den Opiumhandel. Die heute die lautesten Verfechter des Kriegs gegen Drogen sind. Und relativ schnell, nach der Unabhängigkeitserklärung, haben die erst mal angefangen, auch Opium nach China zu verkaufen. Und weil die Briten halt ein Monopol in Megalien hatten, mussten sie das von woanders her holen und haben es dann aus der Türkei geholt. Und also auch die Portugiesen wollten natürlich nicht einfach aus dem Handel aussteigen und haben sich dann versucht, in Westindien, in unabhängigen Provinzen da das Opium zu beschaffen. Aber der Hafen, über den es rausgeschippert würde, der war immer noch in Bombay, ein britisch kontrolliertes Gebiet. Und so haben die Briten einfach irgendwelche obszönen Wegezolle erhoben und haben das damit kaputt gemacht. Also genau, wie heute vorgegangen wird. Das geht alles, alles jahrhundertelange Tradition.
Und nach dem zweiten Opium-Krieg ist China zum weltgrößten Opium-Produzenten geworden. Also die haben...
Und Konsument sowieso.
Und Konsument, ja. Und die haben, was war, genau, 1897 haben 6.700 Tonnen produziert. Also es ist ungefähr so viel, wie heute so im Schnitt aus Afghanistan kommt. Und 1906 hat China 35.000 Tonnen Opium pro Jahr produziert.
Und das war noch nicht mehr die gesamte Weltproduktion, sondern es waren aber immerhin 85 Prozent der Weltproduktion.
Und ja, und wie gesagt, ein Viertel der männlichen Bevölkerung waren, erwachsenen männlichen Bevölkerung waren reguläre Opium-User. Und ja, also das heißt, dass die Zahl, die hier ist, was, 13,5 Millionen Leute haben 39.000 Tonnen Opium jährlich konsumiert. Unglaubliche Mengen.
Damit sind wir in China fast am Ende. Es gibt noch eine erwähnenswerte Sache, nämlich hat unter Mao China die einzige je funktionierende Opium-Prohibitionen auf der Welt hingekriegt. So weitgehend. Also die haben natürlich dann den Vorteil gehabt, dass sie ihre Grenzen einfach mal zugemacht haben. Und immerhin auch nach Afghanistan, was ja kein Teil der Sowjetunion war. Und das hat gereicht. Sie haben also auch richtig harte Maßnahmen gemacht. Ich habe das Thema rausgesucht. Also die haben zehn Millionen Abhängige, haben sie einfach gezwungen an einer, was würde man heute sagen?
Umherziehungslager, würde man wohl sagen.
Ja gut, also damals Umherziehungslager, heute würde man sagen Entzugsklinik. Und sie haben die Verkäufer, die sie gefunden haben, oder Schmuggler, die haben sie einfach mal exekutiert. Und in den Regionen in China, wo Opium angepflanzt wurde, sind sie halt hingegangen und haben andere Sachen drüber gepflanzt. Und na gut, wenn man damit so hart der Hand ran geht, dann kriegt man tatsächlich auch eine Prohibition hin. Daraufhin sind natürlich die Chinesen einfach mal zwangsweise vom Opium weggekommen. Das hat dann wieder aufgehört, als sie die Grenzen jetzt wieder aufgemacht haben. Seit 2000 oder so gibt es wieder mehrere, ich weiß nicht, jetzt waren es Millionen, aber es gibt also eine ernstzunehmende Anzahl an Opium-Abhängigen wieder in China.
Ja, und dann hat sich halt die Opium-Produktion nach Süden verlagert, in das sogenannte Goldene Dreieck, also in Richtung Thailand-Boma. Und da waren dann auch, kommen wir auch noch dazu, die westlichen Geheimdienste durchaus beteiligt daran, da die Produktionen anzufahren, also einfach diese Verlagerung zu betreiben, weil es natürlich eine gute Profitquelle war. Und ja, dann führte das eben doch dazu, dass in Zeiten des Vietnamkriegs, also eine dieser Zahlen, dass 20 Prozent der Soldaten, der US-Soldaten im Vietnamkrieg, sich als Opium abhängig bezeichnet hat 1971. Also da sieht man schon so die Außenmasse, die sowas annehmen kann. Was man halt dazu sagen muss, Opium ist halt geraucht, macht halt Tiefen entspannt und da ist einem die Welt einigermaßen doll egal. Und das schüttet halt eine große Menge Glückshormone aus und führt halt einfach dazu, dass man halt einfach sich wirklich hier vollständig entspannt, was natürlich irgendwie in so einem Krieg halt irgendwie eine Sache ist, die man dann doch gelegentlich mal haben möchte. Das kann man schon verstehen.
Ja, zwei kleine Sachen habe ich noch zu Opium. Das erste ist, dass die die Handelskriege zwischen den Ostindien-Kompanien auch zu zu Innovationen geführt haben. Das kann man heute noch bei den bei den Koka-U-Booten sehen, zu dem wir nachher noch kommen. Aber es war auch damals so, dass die Menge, die man transportieren musste, klein genug war, dass im Grunde, wer zuerst da war, konnte eben den höchsten Profit machen. Und daher haben die damals angefangen mit Schiffstypen zu experimentieren. Und die Klipper-Schiffstypen kommen von daher. Die sind also, ursprünglich, wenn man jetzt auf Wikipedia guckt, steht irgendwas von amerikanischer Erfindung. Aber so der große Einsatz war tatsächlich der Opiumhandel.
Also kleine, schnelle Schiffe, die kleine wertvolle Ladung.
So klein waren die nicht. Das sind so Drei-Master mit quadratischen Segeln. Oder nicht quadratisch, sondern rechteckig. Und die sind sehr schmal. Und also auf Reihen auf Geschwindigkeit ausgelegt. Und das war tatsächlich so ein Rennen dann. Wer zuerst da ist, macht den meisten Profit. Das lag unter anderem daran, dass die Nachfrage in China immer höher war, als was man liefern konnte. Das heißt quasi, egal wie viel Opium man dahingeliefert hat. Es wurde alles weggeraucht. Du hast am meisten Kohle natürlich gekriegt, wenn du der Erste warst, der liefern konnte, weil sie dann so am hibbeligsten waren. Eine Sache, die wir noch ansprechen wollten, ist, wo eigentlich die Idee herkommt, dass man das verbieten muss oder das es schlecht ist. Bei Drogen ist das ja generell so eine Frage. Bei Opium gibt es einen ganz witzigen Datenpunkt, dass die Amerikaner mit dem Verbieten angefangen haben, gar nicht so aus gesundheitlichen Gründen, sondern aus politischen Gründen. Weil nämlich die chinesischen Einwanderer diejenigen waren, die dann in den Opiumhöhlen immer Opium geraucht haben. Und dann haben halt die Amerikaner angefangen zu argumentieren. Von wegen, dass das korrumpiert unsere Bevölkerung und gemeint waren also unsere Töchter. Ja und das war so eine Sache, die sich nicht gegen die Droge eigentlich, sondern gegen die scheiß Ausländer gerichtet hat. Das war so eine ganz rassistische Angelegenheit.
Ja genau, das selbe Muster findet sich dann später im Kokain auch nochmal.
Und bei Haschisch.
Und bei Haschisch stimmt der.
Auch gegen Mexikaner.
Ja und Schwarzwäher.
Genau. Ja also historisch gesehen ist das alles schon 100 mal da gewesen, was wir heute beobachten können. So viel zu Opium. Was kommt?
Ja dann kommen wir mal zum Kokain. Kokain wird der, also die ursprüngliche Herkunft von Kokain ist aus den Blättern des Kokastrauchs. Ein Strauch, der vorwiegend in der anderen Region in Südamerika wächst. Also der braucht halt auch bestimmtes Wetter und bestimmte Höhe und bestimmte Böden und so. Und diese, die Konditionen dafür sind halt in den, die Bedingungen dafür sind in diesen südamerikanischen Ländern, also meistens so Peru, Kolumbien, Bolivien, sind so die drei größten Produzenten am besten. Und die Blätter des Kokastrauchs wurden halt schon seit ewigen Zeiten, also so richtig auch wieder tausend Jahre von den örtlichen Indios gekaut und ist dann halt ein relativ mildes Stimulanz, was irgendwie Durst und Hungergefühl unterdrückt, wach macht, kräftiger, also sich dann körperlich leistungsfähiger macht. Und man muss auch dazusagen, ist halt so, das sind halt irgendwie sehr hohe Regionen, also Bergregionen, von denen wir reden.
Dünne Luft.
Und da ist die Luft halt dünn und da macht es halt einfach, also mit gekauten Koka-Blättern kann man halt einfach sehr viel einfacher aushalten. Dementsprechend also so sieht halt auch die Anwendung heutzutage dann noch aus. Das ist halt so, das wird da immer noch traditionell verwendet und also mit Kauen halt. Und die Isolierung des, also noch ein wichtiger Punkt davor, als die Spanier dahinkamen, haben sie das halt erstmal für irgendwie so ein Gerücht gehalten, das ist ungefähr so wie mit Asterix und dem Zaubertrank, als die Römer zum ersten Mal davon gehört haben, und man sagt, der war für einen Bullshit.
Machen wir erst mal Steuern laufen.
Nee, das haben sie dann gemacht, als sie sich davon überzeugt hatten, dass das kein Unsinn ist, sondern tatsächlich wirksam ist. Dann haben sie halt 10 Prozent Steuern auf Coca erhoben.
Also schon Feldforschung betrieben.
Die haben dann offenbar schon ein bisschen Feldforschung betrieben. Und da passiert dann halt erst mal diverse 100 Jahre gar nichts, weil die Coca-Blätter funktionierten halt nur frisch. Das heißt, so Kühlungen gab es damals noch nicht. Und bis die halt in Europa waren und beforcht werden konnten, waren die halt meistens schon so ein bisschen vergammelt und halt nicht mehr so frisch, dass man da irgendwie ernsthaft was mit anfangen konnte. Und die Chemie war halt auch nicht so weit, als dass man da so ein Alkaloid, also das Kokain daraus extra hier dann standardisieren kann. Das passierte dann erst so 1855, als wieder mal ein Deutscher es tatsächlich geschafft hat, halt da die Extraktion zu machen. Und dann ging es halt relativ schnell. Also da gab es dann halt gerade in der Medizin halt eine relativ weitgehende Anwendung als Lokalinistätikum. Also das Zeug, ich weiß nicht, wenn ihr euch immer beim Zahnarzt mal seid oder so, das Zeug, was ihr euch da in den Graumen spritzen, heißt Novokain. Es hat also, Kain ist seitdem halt so der, ja das Kennzeichen einer Substanz, die halt eben Kokain-ähnliche Wirkung als Lokalinistätikum hat, nur das Novokain halt nicht die stimulierende und euphorisierende Wirkung hat.
Aber kann schon abhängig machen, oder war das nicht so?
Novokain? Glaub ich nicht, nee. Also ich weiß nicht, wenn du darauf stehst, das ist irgendwie...
Nee, also man hört immer, dass die ganzen Anästhesisten ein Abhängigkeitsproblem haben, aber das kann auch...
Achso, das weiß ich nicht, da müssen wir mal einen Experten dafür fragen. Würden wir mal einen anonymen Anästhesisten zum Thema Medikamentenmissbrauch finden. Ja, würden wir da auch nochmal was zu machen. Naja, jedenfalls, ähm, äh, das war das auch bis noch in relativ jüngerer Zeit, oder wird, glaub ich, sogar immer noch verwendet, für bestimmte Augenoperationen als lokalen Ästhetikum. Das ist halt offenbar immer noch das effizienteste Alkaloid. Und wie immer ist halt die Popularisierung da über Behauptungen von medizinischen Wirkungen passiert. Das heißt also, es wurde zuerst angepriesen als wirksam gegen pelzige Zunge am Morgen und Verdauungsbeschwerden und wurde dafür verwendet, die Zähne zu weisen, was natürlich völliger Unsinn war.
Das verkauft sich heute noch großartig in Amerika. Die stehen tierisch auf Zähne weisen. Wir haben gar mal nachgeguckt, also es macht nicht abhängig. Frank hat recht. Aber es gibt hier noch ein lustiges Faktoid am Rande.
Novokain meinst du jetzt?
Ja. Nämlich, dass sie das verkauft haben als Anti-Aging-Medikament, was die Leute verjüngt und das ist tatsächlich medizinisch untersucht worden. Und in den 60er Jahren haben sie dann entschieden, dass das Unsinn ist.
Na gut, also jedenfalls die häufigste Anwendung, gerade in Europa, von Kokain war der sogenannte Kokainwein. Ein italienisches Produkt hieß Vien Mariani. Und der Alkohol in dem Wein hat einfach die Blätter aus den, das Kokain aus den Blättern gelöst. Das heißt also, man hat einfach die die Koka-Blätter in den Wein reingeschmissen und hat dadurch den Kokain rausgelöst in den Wein.
So entfernt sind ja die aktuellen Methoden zur Extraktion auch nicht dann, ne?
Naja, die sind halt schon ein bisschen involvierter, aber Ja, aber immer noch Alkohol. Naja, ne. Also die Kommen wir gleich zu. Ja, können wir gerade bei der Gelegenheit ja mal erzählen. Also die, wie man heutzutage Kokain extrahiert, ist halt eben nicht mit Alkohol. Also der löst halt nur einen Teil. Also man nimmt die Kokainblätter, schnipselt die Kleinen, sprengelt da ein bisschen Kalk oder meistens Zement drauf. So, weil den gibt es halt irgendwie da. Dann lässt man es ein bisschen stehen. Und dann werden die in Benzin eingeweicht, diese Blätter.
Also so Auto-Benzin?
Ja, Auto-Benzin. So Standard-Auto-Benzin. Was dann auch erklärt, warum irgendwie in diesen Filmen, die man so sieht, irgendwie, wo sie dann halt an den Hubschrauber irgendwelche Drogenlabore im Dschungel beschießen, dann wundert man sich, wie so explodieren die denn immer so farbenfreudig? So naja, es liegt halt daran, dass da große Mengen Benzin gelagert werden und halt noch ein paar Anlösungsmittel. Und dann wird, ja, also dann wird die Blätter da drin in dem Benzin eine Weile einweichen gelassen und dann wird es abgeseiht und die Blätter werden ausgetresst, so dass halt irgendwie alle Flüssigkeit rausgedrückt wird. Und in dem Benzin sind dann halt die Alkaloide gelöst. Und die will man jetzt nur daraus haben. Dazu tropft man Batteriesäure, also das Zeug, das man in seine Autobatterie hat da rein. Und dann fällt halt so eine weiße Pumpe da raus. Und diese Pumpe wird dann halt abgeseiht. Und dann gibt es halt so einen mehrstufigen Umkristallisierungsprozess, wo dann noch mit anderen Lösungsmitteln daraus halt dann jeweils das Kokain gewonnen wird. Und die Qualität des Kokains, also wie sie noch nach Benzin schmeckt, hängt unter anderem halt davon ab, wie sorgfältig halt dieser Umkristallisierungsprozess und mit wie reinen Lösungsmitteln, der halt passiert. Und da diese Lösungsmittel natürlich wiederum jetzt mittlerweile halt der Handelskontrolle unterliegen, was also auch zum Beispiel bei der Heroinherstellung wird, wenn auch verschiedene Chemikalien verwendet. Und diese Chemikalien sind halt kontrolliert, weil sie versuchen halt indirekt darüber halt die Drogenherstellung auszutrocknen.
Dann siehst du mal, wie hilflos die sind, oder?
Ja klar. So, aber das ist halt einer der Gründe, warum halt irgendwie die größte Teil des weltweiten Chemikalienhandels so hart kontrolliert sind, sind halt ja nicht nur Terrorismusgeschichten so, sondern eben der Versuch halt irgendwie Vorlauferchemikalien von diversen Drogenherstellungsprozessen unter Kontrolle zu bringen. So was halt am Ende natürlich wieder auch nicht hilft, weil die Profitspannen, da kommen wir später auch zu, so hinreichend hoch sind, dass man halt einfach mehr dafür bezahlt. Also bei den, bei Heroin ist es so, dass einer dieser Chemikalien, die kosten normalerweise halt irgendwie so was wie irgendwie so 20 Dollar für so einen Fass oder so und dann zahlen die halt 350 Dollar fürs Fass. Also es ist halt so ein, naja. Und gut, also.
Man kämpft ja halt nicht mit der Sünde, sondern mit der Wirtschaft.
Ja, und zwar mit der Markt, so mit enormen Markt-Kräften. So also um da mal so ein Beispiel zu bringen, ist halt so, dass die, also für das Opium, was man halt irgendwie so braucht, um halt so ein Kilo Heroin herzustellen, braucht man so ungefähr für 620 Dollar Roh-Opium, Preise von 2004. Und wenn das Heroin auf der Straße landet, ist es ungefähr 40.000 Dollar wert. Was heißt also, wir haben halt irgendwie einen Faktor von mehr als 1 zu 40 von der Farm, wo das Opium hergestellt wird, bis zum Heroin, was auf der Straße verkauft wird. Und mit solchen Preisspannen kann man halt einfach ziemlich beliebige Probleme einfach mal abfedern, sowohl beim Schmuggel, als auch bei der Herstellung. Naja, also die, zurück zur Kokain-Herstellung, also denn am Ende ist es dann halt so ein weißes, kristallines Pulver, was dann wiederum in den Kilo-Packungen, wozu von Packungen halt verpackt wird. Und dann wird es halt irgendwie noch in die Abnehmerländer geschippt. Und am Anfang war es halt so, dass Kokain, oder auch in Form dieses Kokain-Vines, wurde halt, irgendwie war halt extrem beliebt. Und da gab es dann halt schon so lustige Sachen wie dieser Wien-Mariani, also dieser Kokain-Vine, der enthielt ursprünglich so was wie 6 Milligramm Kokain pro unzer Wein. Und davon gab es auch die Exportvariante, die hielt dann 7,2 Milligramm pro unzer Wein, weil andere Konkurrenzprodukte ein ähnliches, also eine ähnlich höhere Kokain-Gehalt in ihrem Wein hatten.
Wir sollten vielleicht noch kurz erwähnen, auch sehr witzig, warum die Kolumbianer überhaupt Kokain als Produkt verseuern. Die haben nämlich vorher Haschisch verkauft. Cannabis, ne?
Ja, bis sehr viel später, bis in die 70er hinein, war halt irgendwie das Hauptexportprodukt der Kolumbianer halt irgendwie tatsächlich Marihuana, bis halt dann die Mexikaner und die Kanadier angefangen haben, große Mengen davon anzubauen und ihnen halt der Markt weggebrochen ist. Natürlich ist es halt auch sehr viel effizienter, also halt so, dass natürlich die also die Schmuggel, also Schmuggeln ist halt natürlich ein schwieriges Business und da bevorzugt man natürliche Waren, die ein kleines Volumen haben, sodass man halt, ja, also einfach so eine, so eine einfach rein logistischen Schmuggelprobleme reduziert. Und insofern sind dann Drogen, die natürlich ein hohes, einen hohen Preis pro geschmuggeltes Kilogramm haben und wo das Kilogramm nicht so groß ist, natürlich, sag ich mal, einfach zu schmuggeln, als ja, sag ich mal, so ein Kilogramm Gras oder so. Naja, jedenfalls die, diese Geschichte mit, dass es auch erstmal medizinisch verwendet wurde, ist halt genau dieselbe wie beim, wie beim Heroin, was ja auch erstmal als Hustensaft verwendet wurde.
Also Heroin ist ein Warenzeichen der Bayer AG, die damals noch anders hieß, wie hieß sie? Hab ich jetzt hier gar nicht aufgeschrieben. Das war ein Hustensaft und der sollte auch gegen alles möglich hier helfen, also von Herzkrankheit über Lungen, wie das so ist. Also in den Anfängen der Medizin war ja, gab es eine Menge Wundermittel und Bayer hatte halt zwei große Kloppe am Angebot, einmal Heroin und einmal Aspirin.
Genau, das waren die beiden Blockbuster Medikamente der Bayer.
Und als ihnen dann Heroin kaputtgemacht wurde von den Gesetzen, da haben sie halt umgeschwenkt auf Aspirin.
Man muss natürlich noch dazu sagen, also dieses Coca-Cola, die hat ja am Anfang das Originalrezept, hält sich auch sehr hartnäckig, diese Geschichte. Waren da halt eben auch Coca-Blätter dran. Das war eben zu der selben Zeit, als es halt Kokainwein gab. Und später haben sie dann halt dekokainisierte Coca-Blätter genommen, um die also zu aromatisieren. Die Frage ist halt, wo eigentlich das Krux geblieben ist, was sie nämlich die Kokainisieren rausgeholt haben. Ja, das war wahrscheinlich so ein Koffeinfeuer-Café. Da muss Koffein ja auch anko bleiben.
Das gibt es ja auch im Handel zu kaufen.
Das Koffein?
Ja.
Ja, als Koffeintabletten. Beziehungsweise dann halt ein Coca-Cola. Jedenfalls 1879 wurde Kokain dann eingeführt als Mittel zur Behandlung von Morphinsüchtigkeit.
Das ist überhaupt so ein Trend, der sich durch diese ganzen Drogengeschichten durchzieht. Das ist immer die näst schlimmere Variante, wird immer als Hilfe gegen die Nebenwirkung der Vorgängervariante gekauft.
Beim Heroin war das auch so. War doch zuerst Morphin. Genau. Also das Morphin ist sozusagen ein...
Morphin ist verscheuert worden als Hilfe gegen die Abhängigkeit von Opium, aber trotzdem als gutes Betäubungsmittel.
Genau, Morphin ist sozusagen ein erstgradiger Abkömmling von Opium. Also halt eine reinere, extrahiertere Form, die aber noch nicht chemisch umgesetzt ist.
Und bei Heroin haben sie auch explizit Werbung damit gemacht, dass es nicht abhängig macht, was Bullshit ist.
Und gegen Morphinsüchtigkeit hilft.
Na ja, aber das war nur eins auf einer langen Liste von ganz vielen...
Na ja, aber eine Morphinsüchtigkeit war zum gewissen Zeitpunkt schon halt irgendwie ein ganz großes Problem. Insofern war dann diese...
Wie das so ist mit der Pharma-Branche und ihren Versprechen.
Na jedenfalls so vor, doch mittlerweile, geraumer Zeit, so 1885, konnte man halt Kokain in so diversen Formen in den USA kaufen, so als Zigaretten und als schädlichen mit Pulver drinne und eben auch sogar mit Injektionsnadeln dazu, also mit Spritze dazu.
Das ist übrigens auch bei Tabak historisch das ältere, die ältere Variante, also zumindest in China hab ich das gelesen, dass da Sachen beigemengt waren. Es gibt heute so diese Menthol-Zigaretten, das war historisch in China tatsächlich erst da, bevor es den Reintest gab.
Die haben da Kräuter dazugemischt.
Die haben da mal irgendeinen Scheiß dazugemischt und so ist auch dieses Opium-Zeugs einfach als Freimischung wahrscheinlich gekommen.
Na ja gut, ich meine, es gibt ja diverse Kräuter, die halt so gewisse Effekte haben beim Rauchen. Ja, also nicht nur Hanf, sondern auch noch andere Kräuter. Und insofern, also gibt es ja auch heute noch Leute, die sich selber ihre Räuchermischung machen, weil sie zum Beispiel weniger Tabak auch in Wolland machen, dann zum Beispiel halt Damianer oder Salbei da rein, die halt so ein bisschen milde, ja, Anheitern, so als es halt irgendwie keine, also nicht zu vergleichen mit den Wirkungen von Hanf oder so. Also so Räucher-Gemische, die halt nicht nur reiner Tabak sind, sind durchaus populär. Na gut, wenn man sich so eine Standard...
Das gibt es auch kommerziell, gerade so die große Wiederkehr von irgendwelchen Nachbau, irgendwie Grasmischungen, gratinlichen...
Na gut, die enthalten aber in der Regel halt synthetisches THC. Das ist so Spice und so die...
Ich ziehe den eigenen Alter zurück.
Spice und ähnliche Dinge enthalten halt einfach Cannabuide, die halt anderweitig extraheter hergestellt sind und halt einfach Kräutermischung zugesetzt werden. Und da spielen sie dann so Tricks, wie dass sie Cannabuide nehmen, die halt erstmal nicht so richtig detektiert werden und so. Also das ist halt so der der Moderne, die Moderne meinte. Jedenfalls, bis Anfang des 20. Jahrhunderts konnte man also Kokain halt noch völlig legal kaufen. Und das war halt auch üblich. Also zum Beispiel gab es ein, wie heißt das Ding, Forced March, also so Gewaltmarch hieß eine Marke von Kokain, Kokain-Tabletten.
Wenn du mal wieder durch Sibirien wandern musst.
In diesem Fall war es halt die Expedition zum Südpol, ja.
Unsere Kunden sind alle, die mal zum Südpol laufen wollten.
Jedenfalls, so 1914 rum fing dann halt irgendwie die moralische Empörung an. Wie immer hat sich das halt irgendwie gegen Ausländer und Schwarze gerichtet. Da war es dann halt so, dass die Behauptungen kamen, so von wegen die Schwarzen greifen weiße Frauen an, wenn sie auf Coke sind. Und dann haben sie halt das in so einem Massenmedien-Craze draus gemacht, um halt irgendwie das ja auch verbieten zu können. Und dann wurde dann...
Da muss ich mal kurz eine Anekdote einwerfen. Also ich habe ja ein bisschen rumgeklickt und bin unter anderem zu Chomsky gekommen, den kennt man ja von seinen Klassenkampftheorien. Und er meint, dass Drogenprohibition generell eine Klassenkampfsache sei. Und er führt das aus und behauptet, dass es gab mal eine Zeit in England, bei der Gin verboten war, aber nicht Whisky. Und ist natürlich beides harter Alkohol, aber die Begründung war eben, Gin wird von den Unterklassen getrunken und Whisky wird von den Oberhausleuten getrunken. Und wir müssen ja nur den verbieten, was irgendwie so die prekären Leute da hat. Und der erzählt auch...
Die nicht damit umgehen können.
Genau. Und der erklärt auch, wie es in Amerika zur Cannabisprohibition kam. Und das ist eine spannende Geschichte. Und zwar war das kurz nachdem die Alkoholprohibition gescheitert war. Also die Alkoholprohibition, da kennen wir ja, hat zu Al Capone und ähnlichen Sachen geführt. Und nachdem das gescheitert war, saßen sie also auf einer großen Enforcementbehörde, die plötzlich keine Aufgabe mehr hatte. Und dann haben sie halt nach was anderem gesucht und haben tatsächlich so eine Art Ausschreibung gehabt, welche Wissenschaftler ihnen Substanzen vorschlagen können, die sie verbieten können. Genau. Und da kam dann, also sie haben keinen Mediziner gefunden, der Cannabis verbieten konnte, weil es da einfach keine Argumente für gab. Aber sie haben irgendeinen, so einen, wie sagt man, Charlatan gefunden, der hat an Hunden Tierversuche durchgeführt und hat behauptet, seine Hunden würden wahnsinnig, wenn man ihnen Cannabis gibt. Und so war dann die offizielle Begründung fürs Cannabisverbot, dass man davon wahnsinnig wird. Und das hat den bizarren Effekt gehabt, dass Strafverteidiger vor Gericht angefangen haben, ihre Klienten damit rauszuholen, dass sie gesagt haben, der war wahnsinnig, weil er Cannabis genommen hat. Und so sind Leute freigesprochen worden, die zum Beispiel einen Polizisten umgebracht hatten. Und völlig klar, da braucht man also eine neue Begründung dafür, warum Cannabis jetzt verboten ist. Und dann haben sie noch mal gesucht. Und die Begründung heute ist eben, es ist eine Gateway-Drug, also eine Einstiegs-Droge für härtere Drogen, wofür es ja auch im Grunde keine ernst zu nehmenden Beweise gibt. Aber also ich meine, das kann man jetzt sehen, ob man das glauben will oder nicht, aber die Geschichte ist schön genug, dass man sie hier mal weitergeben kann.
Na ja gut. Also jedenfalls haben sie dann nach und nach halt einfach auch Kokainverboten, aber lustigerweise haben sie es zuerst als Narkotikum klassifiziert, was natürlich völliger Bullshit ist. Was ist denn das Gegenteil? Das komplette Gegenteil. Es ist halt so eine massive Stimulanz. Und die haben dann erst 1970 wurde es auf die Liste der kontrollierten Substanzen aufgenommen. Also erst dann war es halt so richtig vollständig illegalisiert. Und so als Referenz, so man sagt halt so der 2005, der Markt für Kokain in den Vereinigten Staaten war etwa 70 Milliarden Dollar Street Value. Also das, was tatsächlich dafür an Geld ausgegeben wurde von den Usern. Das halt also schon, dann kann man sich so überlegen, halt schon eine doch durchaus beachtliche Menge Geld, die man da da los wird.
Und das vor allem tatsächliches Geld und nicht so Phantom Geld, wie womit die Bailouts jetzt da hantieren.
Ja, es ist Bargeld. Strukturell handelt es sich dabei um große Mengen Bargeld.
Es gibt so einen ganz lustigen Film, den wir auch auf die Liste tun werden, der heißt Kokain Cowboys. Und da geht es um Miami und Florida generell. Das war halt im Grunde Brachland, so ein Sumpfgelände. Miami war bei weitem keine Millionen Metropole wie heute, sondern war halt so ein größeres Dorf im Grunde. Es gab da auch keine richtigen Hochhäuser und alles. Und dann fing halt der Opium-Schmuggel an.
Kokain.
Entschuldigung, der Kokain-Schmuggel durch Miami. Und zwar deswegen, weil der Schmuggel über Fidel Castro's Kuba ging von allen bizarren Routen, die es halt gibt. Ging das halt über Kuba und dann die Keys nach Miami. Und da ist so viel Geld geflossen, dass der, also es gibt ja immer die Federal Reserve, gibt es nicht nur auf Federal-Ebene, sondern die haben auch in den einzelnen Bundesländern jeweils dann eine Filiale. Und die Filiale in Florida hat mehr Geld durch ihre Geldzählmaschinen gejagt, als alle anderen Feds zusammen. Also da sind so unglaubliche Beträge geflossen. Der Film ist wirklich witzig. Also wenn ihr den mal irgendwo seht, wenn er mal wieder irgendwo ausgestrahlt wird, den kann ich nur empfehlen.
Dieses Handeln von so großen Bargeltenmengen, die halt beim Drogenhandel anfallen, ist ja auch ein echtes Problem. Also wenn du so drogenhinder bist und importierst halt große Mengen Drogen und kriegst dafür relativ viel Geld. Also für einen Kilo Kokain kriegst du so Großhandelstechnisch so zwischen 12.000 und 20.000 Dollar pro Kilo. Verkauft wird es dann halt so für etwa Faktor 5 auf der Straße. Dann musst du halt dieses Geld irgendwo loswerden. Also du kriegst dein Geld natürlich bar und musst es halt irgendwo loswerden. Du musst es halt irgendwie in die normale Wirtschaft schmuggeln. Und da lese ich gerade ein interessantes Buch, der heißt The Infiltrator, My Secret Life Inside the Dirty Banks Behind Pablo Escobar's Medellín-Kartell von einem ehemaligen amerikanischen undercover Agenten, der halt mal diesen ganzen Geld-Kreislauf infiltriert hat und beschrieben hat. Ich bin noch nicht ganz durch, aber auf jeden Fall liest sich es schon mal sehr interessant, wenn man immer so ein bisschen so einen Eindruck davon bekommt, in welchem Niveau die da so spielen. Man muss sich halt vergegenwertigen. Wenn man also pro Kilo von diesem, von Kokain, wenn man es halt irgendwie schafft, das aus Südamerika nach, ja, zum Beispiel nach Miami zu schaffen, hat man halt irgendwie so in der Größenordnung sowas wie irgendwie 10, 15.000 Dollar reingewinnen. Manchmal sogar noch mehr, wenn man halt noch den Straßenverkauf selber organisiert. Das heißt, dann kann es auch gerne mal das Doppelte sein. Für ein Kilo, also wir machen uns jetzt mal, überlegen uns mal kurz, das ist so ungefähr so viel wie eine Milchtüte. Das heißt also, du bringst halt eine Milchtüte von irgendwie Medellin nach Miami und kriegst dafür irgendwie 15.000 Dollar. So und oder eben mehr, je nachdem. Also wenn du halt auch gewisse Ausgaben beim Kauf, den Straßenverkauf organisierst, dann kriegst du halt eben auch mal entspannt 30.000 Dollar dafür. So und dementsprechend kann man sich dann halt auch mal völlig problemlos zum Beispiel ein Flugzeug One Way kaufen. Also da gab es häufiger, also am Anfang, bevor sie da halt vielleicht eine Radüberwachung hatten, gab es einen Handel, wo sie einfach Chessners, die sich halt irgendwo in Mittelamerika, in der Reichweite, haben sie die gekauft, so in Panama zum Beispiel, haben die voll geladen und sind damit nach Miami geflogen. Und dann die wieder zurück zu fliegen, war halt tierisch aufwendig. Die haben sie halt gelassen, dann haben sie die halt wieder verkauft. Da gab es halt so einen Parallelhandel von Leuten, die halt einfach...
Deswegen ist Chesna so erfolgreich, ja?
Naja, um die Umsatzrate.
Vor allem ist dir auch egal, was du dann als Wiederverkaufswert kriegst, ne?
Ja, das ist völlig wurscht. Das ist total irrelevant. Das ist halt irgendwie, also wenn es halt irgendwie, ja, sowas wie irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 10 Kilo oder sowas ist dann halt irgendwie so ein Chesna.
Und transportiert aber sowas wie 400 Kilo, ne?
Ja, genau. Das ist halt so die Briefmarke halt irgendwie dann bei der Gelegenheit.
Und in dem erwähnten Film gibt es übrigens noch ein anderes witziges Detail, was hier so ein bisschen passt. Also da haben sie erzählt, wie sie das Kokain dann verteilen. Und zwar laden sie das in Autos rein und sorgen natürlich dafür, dass irgendwie auf dem Weg, das durch mehrere Hände geht, damit also der Empfänger und der Losversender nie sich gegenseitig sehen. Und dann haben sie aber immer noch das Problem, was ist denn, wenn die Polizei sie anhält? Dann hast du ja immer noch das Problem, wenn der hinten alles voller Koks ist, das irgendwie erklären zu müssen. Und da haben diese, die Schmuggler, haben dafür eine Abschleppfirma gegründet. Das heißt, die haben immer ein Auto gehabt, wo der hintere Teil voller Koks war und haben den dann aber nicht gefahren, sondern haben den abgeschleppt und haben also auch einen richtigen Auftrag gehabt, den sie vorweisen konnten. Und so, selbst wenn sie aufgefangen wurden, dann war zwar das Koks weg, das ist zwar auch ein Herberverlust, aber naja. Aber man konnte ihnen also nichts anhängen, weil sie waren ja nur, ich bin ja hier nur der Abschlepper. Also das ist schon ganz witzig, was für Ideen die Leute sich dann ausgedacht haben. Zu diesen Chessners noch ein anderes Ding. Es gibt so eine Community aus Planespottern. Also man kennt ja von den Briten die Trainspotter. Sowas gibt es auch für Flugzeuge. Und die beobachten dann, also Flugzeuge haben immer außen sichtbar so eine Nummer dran, so ein Code, an den man sie zuordnen kann. Wenn man mit guter Auflösung in seinem Fernglas da guckt, dann kann man das also festhalten, welches Flugzeug das gerade war. Und diese Leute beobachten also auch Kleinflugzeuge, was eigentlich überhaupt nicht festgehalten wird weiter. Es gibt schon gar keine Archive von. Und da fallen immer wieder so auf, es gibt immer wieder Flugzeuge, die auffallen, die dann sowohl in Miami wie auf dem Weg nach Nicaragua oder was gesehen werden, die dann aber auch in England gesehen werden, wenn gerade irgendwelche Geiseln ausgetauscht werden. Und da kommt eine florierende Verschwörungstheorien-Szene von nur von erwischten CIA-Flugzeugen, die da angeblich gerade irgendwelche Gefangenen transportiert haben. Wir haben eine Site verlinkt, die bekannt dafür ist, dass sie da immer wieder solche Storys hat. Aber es taucht auch tatsächlich gelegentlich, kommt es vor, dass irgendein Flugzeug abstürzt, wo ganz viel Koks an Bord war. Und bei der Gelegenheit kommt die lokale Polizei dann auch nicht drum herum, mal zu gucken, wem das eigentlich gehört. Und da kommen auch die bizarrsten Geschichten raus, weil sowas gehört dann vielleicht mal in irgendeiner Coverfirma, die schon dafür bekannt ist, dass sie für die CIA arbeitet und so. Also da gibt es mannigfaltige Verflechtungen. Auch monetär gesehen gibt es da durchaus Interesse daran, diesen Drogenschmuggel aufrechtzuerhalten von so einer Regierung wie der US-Regierung. Selbst wenn man die Drogen selbst nicht haben will. Also es gibt hier vor kurzem jetzt Anfang April gab es so einen Fall von der Wachovia Bank, die ist eine der Bailout-Empfängerinnen in Amerika gewesen, eine relativ große Bank, die gehört jetzt zu Wells Fargo. Und die sind also erwischt worden, wie sie 378 Milliarden Dollar für Drogenkartelle gewaschen haben in Mexiko.
378 Milliarden Dollar?
Ja, und der Artikel schreibt hier, das ist ein Drittel von dem Bruttosozialprodukt von Mexiko.
Das ist ungefähr so eine Größe von so einem halben Bundeshaushalt etwa.
Ja, das ist amtlich. Ist nicht wenig. Und die sind jetzt erwischt worden. Und ihre Strafe war, dass sie 110 Millionen, also nicht Milliarden, Millionen abgeben. Genau, das ist die Briefmarke. Und dann gibt es noch eine furchtbare Strafe von 50 Millionen, die sie auch noch zahlen müssen. Das war's. Also das heißt, es lohnt sich so überhaupt nicht, da mit aufzuhören. Die Strafen, die da verhängt werden, sind so grotesk wenig, dass man also im Grunde sagen muss, dass es offensichtlich kein ernsthaftes Interesse daran gibt, diese Geldströme versiegen zu lassen. Denn die sorgen dafür, dass es an US-Aktienmärkten Liquidität gibt und dass die US-Banken Liquidität haben. Genug Liquidität, um so ein Hypothekenproblemchen, Bläschen zu überstehen, wie das da gerade geplatzt ist.
Das ist eben doch tatsächlich so sehen, dass die Menge an Geld, die da unterwegs ist, hat wirklich volkswirtschaftliche Dimensionen. Das heißt, sich diesen Geldern zu verwehren, also die Wirtschaft so zu bauen, dass die Gelder da nicht durchließen können, hat dann auch wirklich richtig volkswirtschaftliche Implikationen. Ein dezenter Hinweis war, als es darum ging, die Scheinstückelung für die Euronote festzulegen. Ja, genau, super. Und zwar ist es so, dass die größte Dollarnote, die es gibt, seit ewigen Zeiten sind es 100 Dollar.
Das war ja auch mal richtig geldwert.
Das war halt auch mal richtig geldwert, so ne. Und als dann die Euronoten eingeführt werden sollten, haben die Amis halt richtig Druck gemacht, dass irgendwie die größte Note 100 oder 200 Euro sein sollten.
Höchstens.
Eigentlich 100.
Genau. Und die Deutschen haben gesagt so, nö. Wir haben ja die 1000 Mark-Scheine gehabt. Und der 1000 Mark-Schein, der hat halt irgendwie seine Berechtigung, weil die Deutschen natürlich eine sehr bargelt geneigtes Völkchen sind. Und wir wollen halt ein Äquivalent haben. Und dann haben die halt eine Weile hin und her überlegt, was sie jetzt machen. Und dann haben sie am Ende auf Druck der Deutschen entschieden, dass es eben eine 500-Euro-Note gibt.
Von denen es genauso viel physisch gibt, wie es 100-Euro-Noten gibt.
Genau. Und hat schon jemand von euch mal ein 500-Euro-Schein gehabt. Also ich hatte neulich mal tatsächlich eine Hand, zufällig.
Das ist halt für Drogenschmuggler.
Neuer ist halt für bargeldgeneigte Logistiken.
Ja, wie schon sagte.
Naja, und das führt halt irgendwie schon zu einem Eindruck davon, wie wichtig halt dieses Drogengeld ist. Also man muss sich überlegen, jedes Jahr aus den USA alleine 70 Milliarden Dollar, die halt einfach dafür bezahlt werden, das ist wahrscheinlich sogar mehr, nur für Kokain. Also und das ist halt nur eine, tatsächlich nur eine Droge. Und die, also das führt dann halt zu so lustigen Auswirkungen, wie das in den USA zum Beispiel Gesetze gibt, dass Geldzielmaschinen, also dass du für eine Geldzielmaschine besitzt, musst du einen invaliden Grund dafür haben. Das heißt also halt irgendwie ein Business oder so haben, weil sonst ist das irgendwie...
Casino betreiben.
Ja oder halt irgendwie, jedenfalls so ein Business, in dem eine große Menge bargelt. Und so und das ist halt irgendwie schon so ein Hinweis darauf, also wie hilflos diese Versuche, der einen und der anderen da gerade sind, so.
Na bitte nicht nur hilflos, sondern es hat schon den Andruck, als wollen die gar nicht, dass die Erfolg haben, sondern es geht eher darum zu simulieren, dass man was tut. Also es ist ja nicht nur der Drogenteil, der da spannend ist und die Geldmenge, sondern auch der Teil, dass es überhaupt so einen Geldfluss gibt, der im Untergrund läuft, macht es schon attraktiv, wenn man damit Dinge anstellen will, die auch im Untergrund bleiben. Nehmen wir mal an, man ist ein Geheimdienst und man möchte jetzt eine politisch sensible Operation durchführen. Also eine, bei der das bekannt geworden ist, ist die Iran-Contra-Affäre. Da ging es darum, in Südamerika linksgerichtete Regimes abzusetzen, insbesondere die Sandinistas. Und die CIA hatte also den Auftrag da was zu tun, aber sie hatten vom Kongress nicht tatsächlich Budget dafür alluziert bekommen. Und die Lösung, die sie hatten, ist, dass sie Waffen in den Iran liefern, also aus heutiger Sicht super. Und diese Waffen sind sogar teilweise über Israel an den Iran geliefert worden. Also kann man sich gar nicht mehr vorstellen, dass das stattgefunden hat. Und mit den Erlösen von diesen Waffen unter Umgehung eines US-Embargos gegen Waffelieferungen in den Iran haben sie dann die Contras in Nicaragua finanziert. Und das ist also, naja, man würde sagen Opposition, aber es ist also eigentlich so Kirilias gewesen, die sie da finanzieren wollten, die unter anderem ihr Geld mit Drogengeschäften gemacht haben. Das heißt, mit dem Geld haben die Contras dann ihren Kokainanbau gemacht und haben das nach in die USA verkauft, natürlich, weil die USA der größte Kunde für Kokain ist. Und die CIA musste das dann decken, weil sie ja den Contras helfen wollte. Und so kam es zu bizarrsten Effekten. Also es gab zum Beispiel einen Fall, das war jetzt nicht die Contras, sondern das war irgendwas mit Venezuelan. Was hab ich mir hier aufgeschrieben? Genau, da ging es um einen früheren venezuelischen Anti-Narkotik-Chief, also der Polizeichef, der für Drogenprohibition zuständig war und der hat auch lange Jahre für die CIA gearbeitet. Und der ist dann irgendwann erwischt worden, wie er mehrere Tonnen Kokain in die USA geschmuggelt hat und ist vor Gericht gestellt worden in den USA. Das Warenhaus gehörte der CIA, aus der das Kokain kam. Genau. Und der ist also vor Gericht gestellt worden und hat gesagt, zu seiner Verteidigung hat er vorzubringen, dass alle seine Drogeschmuggeloperationen von der CIA approved waren. Also die wussten nicht nur davon, die haben gesagt, kannst du machen. Und also da gibt es einige Fälle von, wo Leute tatsächlich glaubhaft machen konnten. Und es gibt auch einen lustigen Fall, wo sich der DEA-Chef, also die Drug Enforcement Agency, der Amerikaner, der sich beschwert hat, dass er irgendwie so und so viele Leute hops genommen hat. Und von zehn haben irgendwie acht sich damit rausgeredet, dass sie von der CIA Immunität zugesiert bekommen hätten. Also das hat schon echt Ausmaße auch angenommen, die beeindruckend sind.
Das beschreibt er hier auch in diesem Infiltrator-Buch. Die haben dann halt irgendwann wirklich große Mengen der Geldwäsche von diesen Kartellen erledigt. Also die haben die tatsächlich betrieben. Das heißt, die haben die Kohle von den Kartellen eingesammelt, lokal in den USA in diversen hunderttausender Chunks. Und haben die dann über so eine elaborierte Konstruktion mit über die Bank for Credit and Commerce International mit einer Konstruktion gewaschen, wo sie...
Das muss man auch mal was eigenes zu machen. Das ist auch ein großartiger Themenkomplex.
Ja, aber gut, also nur um zu verdeutlichen, was die da so tun. Die haben halt so gemacht, dass sie die Kohle zum Teil investiert haben, in den USA selber, in die Immobilien vorwiegend. So daher eben der Boom in Miami zum Beispiel. Und aber auch in den Börsenunternehmen und Brokerages und so. Also so Handelsunternehmen.
Und haben dann, die übrigens auch Risikokapitalfirmen sind mit so was finanziert worden. Also das heißt, die ganzen Blasen, die wir jetzt haben oder hatten, das kann man schon auf Drogengelder zurückführen.
Vor allen Dingen steigt da noch mal der Konsum an.
Na klar.
Das ist selbstversteigend. So also die haben dann halt die Kohle genommen, haben die über diese BCCI, also diese Bank, in deren luxemburgische Filiale, von der haben sie Kredite bekommen auf Collaterals, also Sicherheiten wie zum Beispiel Immobilien oder Firmen, die sie hatten, und haben daraus dann wieder Bargeld ausgezahlt.
Denn die konnten man in Amerika tatsächlich mit Bargeld zahlen, Autos und Immobilien.
Nee, sie mussten die halt schon irgendwie mit mit, also viele Jahre konnte man das.
Das ist eine relativ neue Sache, dass die Autohändler kein Bargeld mehr haben.
Ja, also Boote ist zum Beispiel auch noch so ein Ding, was traditionell in Bare bezahlt wird. Also große Jachten und aber auch Speedboots und so, die man wiederum auch prima benutzen konnte, um das Kokain in Land zu bringen. Also eine typische Schmuggelmethode war, dass die auf relativ großen Schiffen, meistens Fischtroller oder Containerschiffe oder so, außerhalb der Hoheitszone blieben mit den Schiffen, auf denen die Drogen waren, also meistens mit Kokain. Dann sind die mit den Speedboots rausgefahren, die halt so klein und flach sind, dass sie auf dem Radar nicht ordentlich auftauchten, haben die dann vollgeladen mit dem Koks. Wo haben die sich spezialisierte Speedboots für gebaut, die dann halt hinten so 4-5 Tonnen Ladekapazität drin hatten und haben die dann damit an Land gefahren. Und deswegen ist zum Beispiel halt in Florida und anliegend den Gegenden der Preis von Wassergrundstücken, also da wo du mit deinem eigenen Boot anlanden konntest, so dramatisch hochgegangen, weil die natürlich halt immer eigene Stege, also eigentlich eigene Grundstücke mit Strandzugang brauchten, um halt irgendwie die anderen Operationen zu machen.
Das betrifft übrigens auch uns Deutsche, diese Miami-Geschichte. Also in dem Film haben sie das ganz gut dargestellt. Da haben wir diesen amerikanischen Drogenschmuggler interviewt. Der saß also auch im Knast für seine Schmuggelsachen, ist wieder raus und feiert jetzt seinen Lebensabend in Florida und erzählt halt in dem Film aus dem Nähkästchen und meinte, ja, er hat sicher mal mit seiner Frau gestritten. Und dann sind die jeder in ihren Mercedes gestiegen und haben die irgendwie zusammen kaputt gemacht, irgendwie ineinander gefahren oder drauf umgeprügelt oder so jedenfalls sinnlose Zerstörung. Und der meinte, naja, dann sind sie halt wieder zum Mercedes-Dialer gegangen und haben zwei neue gekauft und erkannte sie schon, weil sie da pro Woche irgendwie einen Daimler gekauft haben und haben auch keine Fragen gestellt. Und ich meine, allen Beteiligten ist an so einer Stelle eigentlich klar, dass es keine legalen Grund gibt, einmal pro Woche einen Daimler zu kaufen. Das sind einfach Drogendealer, die so viel Kohle haben, dass sie kein Konzept dafür haben, wie sie das jetzt sinnvoll irgendwie noch anlegen können. Und ja, das hat auch unsere Autoindustrie gefördert, die Drogenkohle. So ist das nicht. Das ist nur die ausländische.
Und diverse andere Industrien, ja. Naja, also jedenfalls diese. Wir waren jetzt gerade zusammen schon so ein bisschen bei den Schmuggel-Operationen und wie die so funktionieren. Und wenn man halt so viel Geld hat, dass man sich halt irgendwie Chestnuts für One-Way-Flügel kaufen kann oder und obendrein noch CRE-Protection hat, dass einem nichts passiert ist. Und der, ja, also das ist halt ein Business, in dem natürlich viel Kreativität freigesetzt wird, wenn man halt irgendwie so viel Kohle hat. Und der...
Gerade auch für uns als Hacker durchaus spannend, was da rauskommt. Also diese U-Boote, das verfolgen wir seit einigen Jahren mit wachsender Begeisterung, was die da bauen.
Ja, also diese diese Schmuggel-U-Boote sind durchaus...
Inzwischen durchaus professionell.
Ja, also das letzte, was sie da hochgezogen haben, war in der Bayer, glaube ich.
Ja, das war so beeindruckend, dass die Experten gerade noch ihre Freunde eingeflogen haben.
Was eben aus Glasfaser gebaut ist, irgendwie 5-6 Tonnen Ladekapazität hatte. Das kann man sich ja ausrechnen.
Und tatsächlich tauchen konnte. Also die davor waren nur so, dass die halt unter der Oberfläche fuhren. Aber so oben guckte noch raus. Und die aktuelle Generation kann richtig tauchen. Also ist Aufstand so, was wir in den Zweiten Weltkrieg hatten.
Ja, wahrscheinlich sogar noch ein bisschen weiter, weil wir heute bessere Batterien haben.
Ja, mit besseren Materialien.
Ja, bessere Batterien und so. Und Radar, nicht so auf dem Radar aufscheinen und so. Naja, und diese, also die Drogenschmuggel halt findet halt auf vielen verschiedenen Wegen statt. So der, was man immer wieder aus einer Zeitung liest, dass sie irgendjemand am Flughafen hochgezogen haben, der sich seinen Darm mit irgendwelchen Kokainpäckchen vollgepackt hat oder Heroinpäckchen. Das sind halt meistens eher, naja, so etwas kleinere Operationen, die halt versuchen, den etablierten, also die etablierten Großschmuggelwege zu umgehen und dadurch halt irgendwie einen höheren Profit zu realisieren. Also es ist halt so, dass die Profite in diesem Geschäft werden halt in mehreren Phasen gemacht. Also einmal von den Anbauern zur Verarbeitung, dass der geringste Profit, also am wenigsten Blatt, halt bei den Bauern hängen. Dann von der Verarbeitung, also vom Rohmaterial zur Droge, zum Handel im Land, zum Großhandel. Von da aus wird dann exportiert in die Abnehmerländer oder in Zwischenstationen. Zum Beispiel geht halt ein Großratteil des Kokain aus, was nach Europa kommt, mittlerweile über Westafrika. Die suchen sich halt immer Wege, wo sich Zwischenstationen haben, wo es relativ wenig Probleme unterwegs gibt. Heißt also relativ wenig Polizei oder Ähnliches, die sich nicht bestechen lassen, unterwegs gibt, die in die Quere kommen können. Und der nächste Schritt ist dann natürlich der Großhandel im Verbraucherland und da dann wiederum in den Mittel- und Kleinhandel bis dann runter zum Konsumenten. Und an jedem dieser Stufen fällt halt Profit ab. Und wenn man jetzt versucht, das zu umgehen, indem man denkt, man ist total clever und hat da jetzt irgendwie eine Methode gefunden, mal irgendwie drei, vier Kilo Kokain in irgendwie ausgehöhlten kolumbianischen Holzstatuen zu schmuggeln.
Alles schon da gewesen?
Ist alles schon da gewesen. Also der Zoll in Frankfurt hat da so ein Museum, wo sie halt so die verschiedenen Schmuggeltricks haben. Und einige davon klappen natürlich so, aber andere sind natürlich irgendwie schon lange da gewesen. Interessant fand ich jetzt diese Geschichte, dass in den letzten zwei Jahren gab es immer wieder ein verschiedene Vorkommen des Bananenkisten aus Südamerika, dass da halt eine Lage Kokain drin gefunden wurde. Und zwar im Supermarkt. Das heißt also, da gab es dann offensichtlich ein kleines Logistikproblem, wo die Leute vergessen haben, das Kokain auszuladen und dementsprechend dann halt erst irgendwie bis zum Endabnehmen der eigentlichen Ware geschafft hat. Und da sieht man halt schon daran, dass es halt irgendwie durchaus üblich ist, dass man halt normale Import-Export-Fahde von Produkten, die aus diesen Ländern kommen, benutzt, um ja eben die Beifracht, also halt irgendwie das Kokain oder Heroin oder was auch immer man an Drogen hat, irgendwie mitzuschmuggeln. Und dann zum Beispiel darauf zu hoffen, dass man im Zielhafen entsprechend bestochene Beamte vorfindet oder dafür sorgt, dass sie da bestochen sind und man durchkommt oder halt zum Beispiel auch Lücken in den Kontrollen genau kennt. Also dass man weiß, dass zum Beispiel halt nur, keine Ahnung, am Wochenende oder Freitags wird halt nicht geräumt, weil dann nicht genug Leute an Lkw oder Containerräumiganlagen vorhanden sind.
Also wir haben ja erzählt, dass in der Herstellung Benzin beteiligt ist. Es gibt durchaus auch Leute, die dann das gelöste Benzin zum Schmuggeln benutzt haben.
Eine Schmuggelmethode, dass man versucht wurde, an Grenzen, wo halt über Grenzen, wo halt normal in so Lkw-Quantitäten Benzin oder Alkohol oder Industriealkohol zum Beispiel transportiert wird, dass man halt einfach da dann richtig viel Kokain in dieses Benzin oder in diesen Industriealkohol reinkippt und die darin löst. Das ist dann halt schon eine große Menge Kokain, die in so einen normalen Lkw passt oder in so einen Tanklastzug. Und dann auf der anderen Seite halt wieder auskristallisiert. Dazu braucht man natürlich dann halt im Empfängerland eine entsprechende Fabrik, also eine entsprechende Anlage, wo man es halt eben wieder rauskristallisieren kann. Der Aufwand ist natürlich relativ hoch, aber die Entdeckungsrisiko ist natürlich gering. Aber auch so im mittelgroßen Maßstab ist Schmuggeln in Tankern, also Tanklastzügen oder auch an normalen Benzintanks von Autos durchaus üblich. Also wird es dann halt irgendwie dicht eingepackt und einfach in den Benzintank unten reingeschmissen. Nach dem Motto, da ist halt schwierig zu kontrollieren. Kennt der Zoll natürlich auch, aber dazu muss er halt erstmal aufmerksam sein. Interessant ist halt, dass bei den typischen Schmuggel-Aufdeckungen in den allermeisten Fällen entweder sind die Schmuggler sehr dumm, also tun irgendwelche Sachen, die sehr auffällig sind und jeder Zoll schon lange kennt, oder der Zoll kriegt Tipp. Das heißt also, der Großteil geht unbeobachtet durch, meinst du? Ja, also die Abfangquoten liegen wohl weltweit betrachtet so zwischen 10 und 15 Prozent. Und der allergrößte Teil von dem, was abgefangen wird, wird aufgrund von Tipps der Konkurrenz abgefangen. Das heißt also, wenn die benutzen halt den Zoll de facto als Methode, ihre Marktmacht durchzusetzen. Man muss halt sich vergegenwärtigen bei den Mengen an Geld, um die es da geht. Ist es halt so, dass der Drogenhandel natürlich ein extrem lukratives Geschäft ist oder Konkurrenzkampf extrem hart ist, natürlich auch mit allen Mitteln geführt wird. Und die sind halt, also man sieht das immer so aus den Filmen, dass sie da alle schwer bewaffnet sind. Das entspricht der Realität. Also wenn man sich zum Beispiel Mexiko gerade anguckt, Mexiko ist ein Land, was gerade de facto die Kontrolle über seine Gesellschaft verliert, weil da so viel Drogengelder unterwegs sind, dass die Kartelle zu separaten Machtentitäten werden, mit eigenen Armeen, mit vorstellend nicht bestochener Polizei. Und also mit eines der bekanntesten mexikanischen Drogenkartelle, die Los Cetas.
Das sind sogar Ex-Massive Forces Leute, ne?
Genau. Das sind ehemalige mexikanische Sondereinsatztruppen, die halt eigentlich zum Einsatz gegen die Drogendealer ausgebildet wurden.
War das nicht die, die oben auf den Hügeln irgendwie sich niedergelassen haben, aus strategischen Gründen?
Die haben halt einfach irgendwann die Seiten gewechselt und haben erst für eines der Kartelle gearbeitet und sich dann selbstständig gemacht haben.
Weil wir halt besser zahlen, ne?
Na, wie gesagt, also am ersten haben sie sich bestecheln lassen, dann haben sie sich halt komplett selbstständig gemacht und haben dann halt ihre Methoden, mit denen sie halt trainiert haben, also ihre Special Forces Methoden, benutzt, um Konkurrenten platt zu machen. Das heißt, da gibt es halt so etliche von diesen superultrabrutalen Überfällen, von denen man also gelegentlich gelissen hat, vorletztes Jahr, wo die halt dann mit 80 Leuten Granatwerfer, irgendwie Maschinenpistolen, halt irgendwie so ein Anwesen der Konkurrenz platt gemacht haben. Man muss sich überlegen, so ein mexikanischer Drogendealer, so ein Anwesen ist halt eine Festung. Also die kennen da schon einiges, die sind da schon einiges durch, da braucht man dann schon ein bisschen, ja ein bisschen Firepower, um da reinzukommen. Das sind halt diese Los Cetas gewesen. Die Machtkämpfe der Kartelle untereinander gehen halt darum, wer jetzt halt eben da den Drogenmarkt in den USA beliefern kann. Und dementsprechend sind dann halt eben auch die korrumpierenden Auswirkungen davon. Und am Ende ist es halt dann die Frage, so was dann halt nun schädlicher ist eigentlich. Ob denn nun eigentlich das, ja, dass die Leute halt mal ein bisschen Koks nehmen, das Problem ist oder dass eben dann komplett das Land vollständig zerfällt, weil eben die Gewinne, die durch die Prohibition ermöglicht werden, halt so hoch sind. Naja.
Also es gab da auch gerade noch so eine Geschichte, die finde ich hier gerade nicht wieder. Da hieß es auch, ich glaube, es war ein mexikanisches Kartell, was dann angefangen hat, bei den Nachbarländern die Waffendepots des Militärs zu bestehlen. Also die sind da so James Bond-mäßig eingeritten und sind dann da mit den Panzerbrechwaffen und irgendwelchen Anti-Luft-Man-Pads rausgelaufen wieder aus den Militärdepots, die ja nun auch nicht geringfügig gesichert sind. Also das ist schon, da ist inzwischen mehr Firepower bei den Kartellen als bei der Polizei. Das ist ein echtes Problem.
Also der am besten dokumentierten Kartelle war ja das von Pablo Escobar. Der war einer der großen Drogenbarone in Middellin.
Der war so ein bisschen zu LK-Pawn mäßig.
Naja, der hatte eigentlich hatte der einen Ansatz, dass er sich halt sehr viel Sympathien in der lokalen Bevölkerung verschafft hat, indem er Sozialstaat gespielt hat und zwar massiv. So der hat da Schulen gebaut und irgendwie Sportplätze, der hat irgendwie Nachbarschaftshilfe finanziert, der hat irgendwie kleinen Businesses Kredite gegeben.
Und so jemanden verrät man dann auch nicht.
Und so jemanden verrät man halt eben auch nicht, genau. Und der hat halt aber natürlich halt eben auch die gesamte Regierung wahrscheinlich korrumpiert, also die Richter, die Polizei, die Staatsanwälte, die Minister, einmal hoch und runter, also einmal komplett alle. Weil man mit so viel Geld kann es das halt tun. Und die halt entsprechende Protektion verschaffen. Und als die eigentlich dann loswerden wollten, haben sie das selber nicht geschafft. Und die haben es dann halt erst mit Hilfe der Amis hinbekommen. Und zwar war es so, dass es dann so ein Gemisch von Interessen gab. Zum einen gab es halt die Konkurrenten von ihm, die ihn halt ein bisschen verraten haben. Also halt einfach den Staat benutzt haben, um ihn loszuwerden. Und zum anderen gab es da halt natürlich eine Menge Leute, die halt einfach ernsthaft ein Problem mit ihm hatten, weil er halt einfach eine Menge Leute umgebracht hat, die ihn so umbringen lassen hat in der Geschichte. Und zwar halt eben auch zum Beispiel von Polizisten und Richtern, die halt nicht bestechlich waren. Das gibt es ja dann doch immer wieder. Und dann haben die zusammen mit den Amis tatsächlich Todesstorrdrohnen installiert, die halt alle Leute, die mit Escobar zu tun hatten, umgebracht haben. Und zwar so den Lehrer seiner Tochter, so irgendwie oder ne, seines Sohnes, und irgendwie seinen Arzt, irgendwie seinen Gärtner, so halt so in dem Stil. Also einfach so dafür gesorgt, dass irgendwie jeder, der irgendwie mit ihm zu tun hatte, war halt seines Lebens nicht mehr sicher.
Bis auf die Familie, ne?
Bis auf die Familie, genau. Und zwar deswegen war er dann halt irgendwann auf der Flucht war, um ihn darüber zu kriegen, dass er versucht, mit seiner Familie zu kommunizieren. Und das ist ihm dann tatsächlich am Ende auch gelungen. Also beschrieben ist das Ganze in einem sehr, sehr guten Buch von Mark Bowden, der auch Black Hawk Down geschrieben hat. Und zwar heißt es Killing Pablo. Ist ein durchaus lohnenswertes Buch. Machen wir noch in die Buchempfehlung rein. Gibt's mittlerweile, glaube ich, auch irgendwo als E-Book in irgendwie diversen Netzen. Und der, also am Ende war es halt so, dass die Amis mit einer Einheit, die gibt's nicht so richtig. Die heißt irgendwie damals, sie ist die Grey Fox. Mittlerweile heißt sie, glaube ich, nur noch The Activity. Und worum es sich da handelt, ist ein Konglomerat von Special Forces, CIA und NSA. Das heißt, die tun da halt irgendwie ihre Kräfte.
Die besten der besten.
Ja, aber tatsächlich so. Die tun halt einfach die Leute, die wirklich was können, zusammen, um halt Operationen, die halt wirklich so deep black sind, zu machen. So und eigentlich.
Bestimmt auch mit Drogengeldern bezahlt am Ende.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Na ja, wie denn sonst?
Kann gut sein, ja. Aber jedenfalls, was die denn getan haben, die haben mit Flugzeugen, die, neben dem Grundnamen Guardrail, das ist ein umgebaute Beachcraft Flugzeuge, wo sie Peilantennen eingebaut haben, haben sie halt Funktelefon und Funkgeräte eingepeilt, unter anderem mit dem Telefon von dem Escobar, wo er versucht hat, mit seinem Sohn zu telefonieren, oder glaube ich sogar ein Funkgerät, ich habe es nicht mehr ganz in Erinnerung. Und darüber haben sie dann seine Lokationen rausgefunden in irgendeinem Slum da. Und dann haben sie da ihre Special Forces reingeschickt und die haben ihn halt einfach weggesnipert. So wie er halt irgendwie da, also es haben sie dann versucht, sozusagen rauszutreiben aus seinem Versteck, in dem sie die Polizei zusammengezogen haben. Dann hat er versucht zu fliegen, aber die waren halt noch gar nicht dran. Sie haben ihn halt weggesnipert vom Dach. Und dann haben sie hinterher dann so dargestellt, dass ihn die Kolumbianer gefunden haben und der auf der Flucht...
Also wir hätten ihn da rechtsstaatlich behandelt, aber...
Flucht über das Dach und der hat schon geschossen oder so. Aber die Geschichte war irgendwie offensichtlicher Bullshit. So, naja. Und der... also diese Geschichte zeigt halt eben auch so wiederum diese Ambivalenz dieses Drogenkrieges. Zum einen hat man da halt irgendwie Geheimdienste, die unter dem Vorwand... man müsse ja noch tiefer das Kartell infiltrieren. Das ist halt immer... Mit Dealen. Mit Dealen und Geldwaschen und so. Und zum anderen benutzen sie dann halt eben solche Methoden, um die aus dem... also die echten Kartelle halt aus der Welt zu schaffen. Natürlich hat es nicht dazu geführt, den Esko bei umzubringen, dass jetzt halt irgendwie der Drogenschmuggel weniger, oder die Regierung weniger korrupt, im Gegenteil.
Die verdienen halt andere daran.
Dann wechselt halt die Macht zu anderen Leuten. Und das wird sich halt so lange nicht ändern, wie halt so viel Geld dadurch zu machen ist, dass halt eben die... ja, das Zeug verboten ist. Also wenn man sich anguckt, der eigentliche Preis, also das war sozusagen der eigentliche Handelswert dieser Ware, ist halt ein Landwirtschaftsprodukt. Also wir reden halt hier von... keine Ahnung, also wenn es hochkommt, maximal irgendwie 1000 Euro pro Kilo oder sowas, was halt irgendwie ein gerechtfertigter Preis für irgendwie sauberes, gut hergestelltes Kokain ist, wo man halt irgendwie auch die Lösungsmittel nimmt und nicht verbleitet Benzin.
Das einzige, was noch teurer ist, ist Drucker-Tinte.
Ja gut, also ich meine, der faire, besteuerte Herstellungspreis von Kokain wäre so was, also wenn man sozusagen eine Apotheke kaufen würde, wäre so was wie 10, 15 Euro pro Gramm oder so. Ja, also es wäre halt irgendwie... und alles, was da drüber ist, ist halt...
da stehen schon die Pharma-Mafia dran.
Und da wurde schon die Pharma-Mafia dran verdient. Und das wäre also jetzt nochmal so einen Vergleichspreis zu setzen.
Das war in China übrigens auch so, dass der Opium-Absatz erst richtig losging, nachdem sie Prohibitionen probiert haben. Vorher war das irgendwie so eine Randgruppentun-Sache. Aber sobald man anfängt, was zu verbieten, geht der Preis hoch und dann geht bei den Leuten das Gefühl hoch, das ist teuer, da muss was dran sein. Und das ist jedes Mal so. Ich meine, es gibt immer wieder die Leute, ah, wir müssen das verbieten, weil es schlecht ist, und dann verbietet man es und dann wird es noch populärer und wir müssen es bekämpfen. Und dann bekämpft man es, dann wird es noch teurer. Und das einzige, was wirkt, ist, wenn man es einfach nicht mehr illegal macht. Das hat Portugal übrigens probiert.
Genau, Portugal hat es getan, die haben halt gezeigt, dass es...
Und alle haben drauf gezeigt und gesagt, oh, das wird jetzt Sodom und Gomorra, die EU wird untergehen im Drogenrausch aus Portugal. Aber das stimmt gar nicht. Also Portugal hat echt Erfolge vorzuweisen. Da ist sogar Heroin legalisiert, ne?
Ja, es ist ein bisschen komplexer. Was sie getan haben, ist, dass du beim Besitz oder angetroffen wärst mit gewissen Mengen, die halt irgendwie sowas wie ein Monat Eigenbedarf sein können in der großen Klasse, wann das du halt nicht mehr ins Gefängnis, sondern du bekommst halt, also wirst halt sozusagen zwangsweise zu so einer Sozialarbeiterkommission geschickt, die mit dir darüber reden, warum du denn drohungssüchtig bist und was irgendwie dein Problem ist und ob man dir nicht helfen kann. Und es gibt auch so richtig medizinische Betreuung und Überwachung, also es ist nicht nur einfach Legalisierung, sondern die kümmern sich halt tatsächlich auch darum. Der interessante Effekt war, dass sie halt vermutet hatten, dass dadurch eben auch der Konsum von Hanfdrogen, also wo es irgendwie keinen großen medizinischen Betreuungsbedarf gibt, außer bei den ganz harten Fällen, die sich halt die Abitur wegkiffen, dass die steigen würde. Was da passiert ist, dass die gesunken sind, eben dadurch, dass es halt nicht mehr verboten, also nicht mehr so richtig illegalisiert ist und dir halt keine ernsthaften Folgen drohen, wenn du halt irgendwie mal mit ein paar Gramm Haschelschnattertaschen angetroffen wirst.
Auch bei den harten Drogen sind die Userzahlen deutlich zurückgegangen.
Die Userzahlen sind ebenfalls deutlich zurückgegangen, was eben auch dazu geführt hat, dass da ich das halt eben nicht mehr so, ja, also nicht mehr so hart illegalisiert ist, sind eben noch die Preise gefallen. Und damit ist natürlich die Beschaffungskriminalität gefallen. Und also alle Auswirkungen, die halt irgendwie immer gesagt wurden, ja, wenn wir das legalisieren, dann bricht unsere Gesellschaft zusammen, sind halt völliger Bullshit.
Also müsste es genau Gegenteil passieren.
Genau. Also es ist halt klar, dass man kann es jetzt nicht einfach legalisieren und sagen, hier, nehmt mal alle irgendwie viel Spaß dabei, sondern man muss sich natürlich darum kümmern. Also man muss halt einfach sagen, okay, Leute, die drogensüchtig sind, also die tatsächlich abhängig sind von Drogen, haben halt ein Problem, um die muss man sich kümmern. Aber in der Regel ist es halt eben so, dass diese Leute sowieso schon ein Problem hatten, um dass sich die Gesellschaft hätte eigentlich kümmern müssen. Also zum Beispiel Heroin-Abhängigen. Es ist so, dass die Anzahl der Leute, die ein psychologisches Problem haben, zum Beispiel ihre Kindheit und das Brauchwohnen extrem hoch ist. D.h. die nehmen dieses Zeug ja nicht, weil es ihnen so viel Spaß macht, sondern weil sie irgendwie mit der Realität klar kommen wollen. So bei Kokain ist es halt so, dass die die Abhängigkeit halt anderer Natur ist.
Das ist eher so eine Leistungssteigerungssache, ne?
Ja, ist eher so eine Leistungssteigerungssache. Da ist es halt aber eben in der Regel auch so, dass die Zahlen der Abhängigen, also der Leute, die wirklich abhängig sind vom Kokain, sind geringer. Andere Sache ist bei Crack. Crack ist halt eine Aufbereitungsform von Kokain, die dafür gemacht wurde, es billiger zu machen. In dem es halt mit Backpulver vermischt wird und gekocht wird. Und das führt halt dazu, dass man halt mehr, also mehr Hai aus weniger Kokain bekommt. Und das haben sie halt ursprünglich mal gemacht, um auch armere Bevölkerungsschichten zu erschließen. Also halt einfach. Und der Nebeneffekt ist aber, dass Crack halt wirklich sehr, sehr abhängig macht. Und das ist halt so eine Droge, wo man schon irgendwie rechtfertigen kann, dass die Gesellschaft halt also es nicht dulden muss, dass halt irgendwie das Zeug in so großen Mengen auf die Straße kommt. Aber wie gesagt, Prohibition hilft da eben auch nicht so.
Das kann man auch wirtschaftlich betrachten. Also ich hab eine andere Beschreibung gesehen, wo Crack herkommt. Und zwar ging es darum, dass man das Risiko beim Schmuggeln minimieren will, indem man nicht das fertige Produkt schmuggelt, sondern nur Vorgängersubstanzen. Und man kann ja mehr Crack verkaufen pro eingeschmuggeltem Opium oder Kokain in dem Fall, als wenn man das Kokain direkt verscheuert. Und wenn man das dann lokal vor Ort, quasi in der Nachbarschaft zusammenpopelt, in irgendeinem Labor, dann wird ein Teil des Risikos einfach abgefedert und dann ist der Transport nicht mehr so teuer und das können dann auch, wenn die verhaftet werden, findet sich jemand anderes, der das macht, also das ist leichter zu ersetzen. Und am besten ist natürlich, wenn der Konsument das selber macht, sondern bist du gar nicht mehr bedroht als Lieferant. Und die Fortsetzung, die logische Fortsetzung von dieser Idee, sind jetzt diese Designer-Chemiedrogen, die man komplett vor Ort synthetisieren kann aus Wustensaft und die Meth-Labs, die in Amerika ein echtes Problem sind. Da gibt es jetzt inzwischen sogar Fernsehsendungen drüber, also so Serien. Wie heißt das? Breaking Bad? Ich weiß nicht, ob du davon gehört hast.
Nee.
Da geht es um einen Chemielehrer, der Krebs hat und der sich denkt, er muss jetzt hier nur für seine Familie vorbauen und der sich dann anguckt, was er mit seinen Fähigkeiten so machen kann, um schnell zu Geld zu kommen. Und dann fällt ihm halt auf, naja, also eigentlich kann er jetzt mal Meth machen. Und dann tut er sich mit so einem Deadbeat Schüler zusammen, von dem er weiß, dass er irgendwie mit selbst Meth macht. Ja, genau. Und produziert ihn dann so ein bisschen Meth. Und der Typ sucht sich dann so, so was Reines hat er noch nie gesehen, weil die ganzen Pfuscher, die das halt am freien Markt machen, sind halt keine Chemiker natürlich. Also das hat es bis in die Populärkultur geschafft. Mir ist das in Amerika ein paar Mal begegnet, das ist ganz witzig, weil die in den Drogerien keinen Hustensaft mehr verkaufen wollten. Also ich meine, da hingen dann so Schilder aus. Ich habe jetzt keinen Husten gehabt, aber ich habe die Schilder gesehen und habe dann mal gefragt und dann haben die mir erklärt, aus diesem Hustensaft, übrigens historisch ganz witzig, weil eben Heroin war ja auch immer Hustensaft. Vorsicht mit dem Hustensaft. Aus diesem Hustensaft kann man Meth machen und um das einzugrenzen sind sie jetzt so verzweifelt, dass sie den Hustensaft nur noch gegen Rezept und Vorlage vom Führerschein, weil Personal das weiß haben sie ja nicht drüben, also Foto-ID heißt es dann immer, Führerschein, und es gibt auch noch eine Quote pro Person. Also das heißt, damit du selbst, wenn du Rezepte vorweisen kannst, kriegst du nur so und so viel davon.
Kriegst du keinen Hektoliter Hustensaft.
Genau. Und der Hustensaft selbst ist natürlich völlig harmlos an sich.
Aber er kann halt zum Miet umgesetzt werden.
Genau. Übrigens, auch bei Heroin war es damals so, dass die Darrechtung als Hustensaft tatsächlich nicht direkt abhängig oder high gemacht hat, weil die Metabolisierung anders stattfindet. Also erst durch Rauchen oder Indizieren ist das die harte Droge, als die wir es heute kennen. Also ist nicht so, dass Bayer damals irgendwie, ich meine, man traut ja den Pharmafirmen viel zu, aber so übel war es nicht, dass sie da harte Drogen als Hustensaft verseuert haben.
Wir sollten vielleicht nochmal, gerade weil wir Pharmafirmen sind, nochmal erwähnen, dass ein Großteil des Drogenmissbrauchs heutzutage tatsächlich verschraubungspflichtige Medikamente sind.
Hast du da was gefunden über den Markt?
Nee, habe ich nicht genauer geguckt, aber deshalb können wir vielleicht nochmal separat machen, wo wir uns noch mal über synthetische Drogen unterhalten, die wir heute rausgelassen haben, weil wir sonst irgendwie das Thema komplett sprengen würden.
Wir haben schon so knapp zwei Stunden zusammen hier.
Das heißt also, dass der Markt, den wir sehen für Entspannungs-Chemikalien, der reflektiert sich natürlich eben auch in den riesigen Mengen an Psychopharmaka, Beruhigungsmitteln und Substanzen wie Tiledin und Ähnlichem, die sozusagen als Drogen verwendet werden.
Was ist denn das? Erklär mal.
Auf Rezept verwendet werden. Da lassen wir jetzt nicht so ins Detail gehen. Interessanter sind halt eigentlich solche Sachen wie Prozac zum Beispiel.
Na und Ritalin.
Ritalin, genau. Die halt irgendwie verwendet werden, um den psychischen Zustand zu normalisieren. Anders kann man es ja kaum beschreiben. Unser guter Freund Rob ist ja der Ansicht, dass die Revolution deswegen ausfallen wird, weil die Leute halt eben alle auf Prozac sind und deswegen halt irgendwie relativ wenig haben, worüber sie sich so aufregen können. Und das ist eine neue Prozac dazu führt, dass...
Das ist im Trinkwasser übrigens. Das wird nicht weiter irgendwie zerlegt oder abgebaut im Körper, sondern das wird wieder ausgeschieden. Und es ist zu signifikanten Anteilen im Trinkwasser.
Aber noch nicht in den wirksamen Bereich gekommen.
Nein, aber das finde ich ja trotzdem schon hart. Weil das betrifft ja nicht nur Menschen. Wer weiß, was das bei Tieren auslöst, die vielleicht eine kleinere Dosis brauchen, um da Wirksamkeit zu haben. Also das ist schon sehr, macht mich jetzt nicht froh, mit Brutgemut zu hören, dass es bewusstseinsverändernde Drogen im Trinkwasser gibt. In Amerika richtig doll. Das ist ja eine richtige Lifestyle-Droge drüben. Das ist so eine Glückspille, die die Leute nehmen, die glauben, sie seien depressiv. Und das ist also fast die gesamte Bevölkerung.
Ich mein, es gibt halt schon...
Nee, das wird ja echt so bultmäßig verkauft.
Ja klar. Also man sollte halt schon sagen, solche Mittel haben halt durchaus eine Berechtigung. Es gibt Leute, die helfen, denen hilft es sehr, irgendwie ihren Alltag zu überstehen. Aber wenn man dann sieht, dass halt irgendwie zum Beispiel Psychotherapeuten keine Zeit mehr haben, um mit den Leuten halt zu reden und denen möglicherweise helfen, ihre Probleme zu lösen.
Ja, ihr nehmt mal eine Pille.
Sondern nur noch tatsächlich die Zeit haben zu gucken, welche Pille braucht denn der, wenn sie halt auf ihren stundenlohn kommen wollen. Dann sind wir halt irgendwie an einem Punkt angelangt, wo wir über diesen gesamten Komplex, ja, sagen wir mal, bewusstseinsverändernde Substanzen und unsere Gesellschaft halt einfach noch mal komplett neu reden müssen. Und wir uns einfach darüber unterhalten müssen, ob denn nicht einfach unser kompletter Umgang mit diesem Thema völlig irrational und bescheuert ist. Eigentlich ist es ziemlich offensichtlich so, wenn halt irgendwie große Teile der amerikanischen, männlichen Bevölkerung, die im Knast sitzt, deswegen die sitzen da wegen Drogenvergehen. Also nicht wegen irgendwie schlimmer Gewaltstraftaten, sondern wegen Drogenvergehen.
Das kommt übrigens über diese Three-Strikes-Scheiße.
Ja, und viele verlieren.
Ja, eigentlich, also ich mein, das ist ein schönes Beispiel, was ich noch kurz erwähnen will. Deswegen für Gesetze, die eigentlich gar nicht doof klingen, aber die in der Folgenabschätzung dann furchtbares anrichten. Also bei Three-Strikes ist die Idee, wenn du zwei schwere Verbrechen hast und dir dann noch irgendwas leistest, dann kommst du lebenslänglich im Knast. Also jetzt irgendwas nicht im Sinne von irgendwie falsch geparkt, das muss schon auch eine Straftat sein, aber auch ein Drogenvergehen reicht, um der dritte Strike zu sein. Und die Idee ist, dass es eine Wiederholungstäter, die können wir eh nicht sozusagen sozialisieren. Und das führt auf der einen Seite dazu, wenn du zwei Strikes hast und der dritte droht, dass du schon mal ein Mord begehst, um den loszuwerden, weil du dann ist ja eh im Knast und hast nichts. Wie ist so schlimmer wird es dadurch nicht? Und auf der anderen Seite sorgt es eben dafür, dass alle möglichen Kiffer ewig im Knast rumgammeln, weil sie eben den dritten Strike sich da angesammelt haben. Und deswegen muss man bei Gesetzen genau nachdenken, bevor man Ja sagt. Das kann sehr schnell nach hinten losgehen. Die Statistik ist so krass, ich habe hier neulich das als Meldung gehabt, da hab ich natürlich gleich Ärger gekriegt von meinen Lesern. Also es gibt gerade so ne Meldung, wenn man nachrechnet, wie viele Schwarze eigentlich versklavt waren zu Sklaverei-Zeiten in Amerika und wie viele heute im Knast sitzen, dann sind es heute mehr. Und es gibt natürlich mehr Schwarze heute in Amerika, insofern ist das kein fairer Vergleich. Aber es macht schon klar, was das für eine Größenordnung ist, die da gerade eingeknastet ist. Und auch ohne Hoffnung. Das sieht ja nicht so aus, als wenn es jemals besser werden könnte. Die Drogengesetze werden ja eher schlimmer mit jeder Iteration.
Genau. Und das Lobbying für hartere Drogengesetze findet zum Beispiel von den Firmen statt, die im privaten Knest betreiben.
Und den Alkohol, den hatten wir das nicht auf der Nordnews-Show mal vor einer Weile. Da gab es irgendwie so...
Achso, ja genau. Und die Alkoholfirmen sind auch für hartere Drogengesetze, weil die Leute dann natürlich auf Alkohol umsteigen. Wenn sie sonst irgendwie nichts finden. Also wie gesagt, unser gesamter gesellschaftlicher Umgang mit psychoktiven Substanzen ist komplett verkackt. Und da muss man, glaube ich, mal ganz grundsätzlich ran.
Immerhin ist noch nicht ganz so verkackt wie in Amerika.
Ja, stimmt.
Also da kommt es durchaus vor, dass es Supermärkte gibt. Also ich war jetzt zum Beispiel in Washington State. Das ist im Nordwesten. Da kann man im Supermarkt Wein kaufen, aber keinen harten Alk. Und dann gibt es Bundesstaaten wie Utah. Da wohnen die Mormonen. Das sind die völlig Kranken. Da kann man überhaupt keinen Alkohol kaufen, habe ich mir erzählen lassen. Und in Texas ist es so, dass man zwar am Sonntag in den Supermarkt gehen kann. Und da gibt es auch ein Alkoholregal. Aber das haben die dann abgesperrt, weil man am Wochenende keinen Alkohol kaufen darf. Und also totaler Bullshit, was die Leute sich da alle überlegen, das sind immer irgendwelche Puritana-Bewegungen. Und wir haben das ja auch versucht, ein bisschen darzustellen bei der Prohibition gegen die anderen Drogen, dass es meistens keine medizinischen Hintergründe hatte, sondern irgendwelche Rassismus-Scheiße war oder irgendwelche Puritana-Geschichten. Und das ist eigentlich eine ziemlich bittere Lektion, finde ich, wenn man sich die Menschheitsgeschichte so ansieht, dass wir uns immer von so einem Blödsinn zu unseren Entscheidungen führen lassen und nicht von rationalen Überlegungen.
Na gut, dann sind wir glaube ich erstmal durch für heute. Und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Und denkt mal ein bisschen drüber nach, wenn ihr mal wieder in Diskussionen über Drogen kommt, was denn die eigentlichen Hintergründe dessen sind und warum es tatsächlich hier so ist, wie es ist. Mit den psychoaktiven Substanzen und was denn so irgendwie im Nachtschränkchen steht, was eigentlich nach normaler Bezeichnung eine Droge sein sollte und nur zufällig Medikament gerade heißt. Und ansonsten, wenn ihr Lust habt, könnt ihr gerne natürlich flattern. Wir überlegen uns noch was Lustiges. Wir haben bisher noch ein paar Bücher gekauft mit dem Geld. Und werden auch demnächst mal wieder noch ein paar Leute einladen zu extra Themen und dann noch einen schönen Abend.
Und bis zum Nachsatz, als Nachsatz sei noch gesagt, dass sogar der Economist findet, dass Drogen legalisiert werden.
Der Economist findet das schon seit vielen Jahren.
Der Economist und zwar gar nicht aus irgendwie humanitären Gründen, sondern aus ökonomischer Betrachtung aus.
Volkswirtschaftlicher.
In diesem Sinne bis zum nächsten Mal.
Bis zum nächsten Mal. Vielen Dank.